Optimal at this altitude,
I can run flat out for a half mile before my hands start shaking.
I'm a cybernetic organism living tissue.
This episode is brought to you by audible,
which I've used for years.
I love audiobooks and I've two to recommend right off the bat.
Number one is press my favorite audio book of all time,
and that is the graveyard book by Neil Gaiman.
The only audiobook I've wanted to immediately listen to a second time.
As soon as I finished.
It's amazing.
You will thank me.
The graveyard book.
The second is vagabonding by Rolf Potts,
which had a huge impact on my life and formed the basis for a lot of what became
the four hour workweek.
So while you need to do to get your free 30 day trial is go to audible.com
forward slash 10 and you can choose one of those two books,
the graveyard book bag of bonding or more than 180,000 audio programs.
So that could be a book.
That could be a magazine,
that could be a newspaper,
could be a class.
It's that easy.
Go to audible.com forward slash Tim,
that's audible.com forward slash Tim and grab a book.
Enjoy.
This episode is brought to you by Wealthfront and this is a very unique sponsor.
Wealthfront is a massively disruptive in a good way,
set it and forget it.
Investing service led by technologists from places like apple and world famous
investors.
It has exploded in popularity in the last two years and they now have more than
two and a half billion dollars under management.
In fact,
some of my very good friends,
investors in silicon valley have millions of their own money in Wealthfront.
So the question is why?
Why is it so popular?
Why is it unique?
Because you can get services previously reserved for the ultra wealthy but only
pay pennies on the dollar for them.
And this is because they use smarter software instead of retail locations,
bloated sales teams,
et cetera.
And I'll come back to that in a second.
I suggest you check out wealthfront.com forward slash Tim,
take the risk assessment quiz,
which only takes two to five minutes and they'll show you for free.
Exactly the portfolio they'd put you in and if you just want to take their
advice,
run with it,
do it yourself,
you can do that or as I would,
you can set it and forget it and here's why.
The value of Wealthfront is in the automation of habits and strategies that
investors should be using on a regular basis but normally aren't.
Great investing is a marathon,
not a sprint,
and little things that you may or may not be familiar with like automatic tax
loss harvesting,
rebalancing your portfolio,
cross more than 10 asset classes and dividend reinvestment add up to very large
amounts of money over longer periods of time.
Wealthfront,
as I mentioned,
since it's using software instead of retail locations,
etc. Can offer all of this at low costs that were previously completely
impossible right off the bat,
you never pay commissions or account fees for everything.
They charge 0.25% per year on assets above the first 15,000 which is managed for
free.
If you use my link,
wealthfront.com forward slash Tim that is less than $5 a month to invest a
$30,000 account for instance.
Now,
normally when I have a sponsor on this show is because I use them and recommend
them.
In this case,
it's a little different.
I don't use wealth front yet because I'm not allowed to.
Here's the deal.
They wanted to sponsor this podcast,
but because of SCC regulations,
companies that invest your money are not allowed to use client testimonials.
So I couldn't be a user and have them on the podcast,
but I've been so impressed by Wealthfront that I've invested a significant
amount of my own money,
at least for me,
uh,
in the team and the company itself.
So I am an investor and hope to soon use it as a client.
Now back to the recommendation as a Tim Ferriss show listener,
you'll get $15,000 managed for free if you decide to open an account.
But just start with seeing the portfolio that they would suggest for you.
Take two minutes,
fill out their questionnaire@wealthfront.com forward slash.
Tim,
it's fast,
it's free.
There's no downside that I can think of.
Walk,
walk,
a walk.
I use Sochi savages.
This is Tim Ferriss and welcome to another episode of the Tim Ferriss Show where
it is my job to deconstruct world class performers,
whether they are from the worlds of chess,
entertainment,
military politics,
athletics,
business or otherwise.
And this episode is a fun one.
It took place in my home on my couch with tea and it involves lessons from
Tinker's geniuses and billionaires and the interviewee is Chris Young and we
talk about quite a few things,
what he's learned from people like Bill Gates,
Nathan Myhrvold and perhaps a name you don't recognize,
but in many ways the most impressive to me self made billionaire Gabe Newell and
if you don't know who he is,
you should learn all about it and we will get into it.
Neal Stephenson,
the science fiction author,
although saying it that way doesn't do justice to the work that he puts out,
which is incredible snow crash and so on.
We'll touch on that and questions above all,
we focus on good questions.
We focus on better thinking and we focus on,
for instance,
how geniuses and people who run,
the number one ranked restaurant in the world,
express disappointment,
how do they express disappointment and ensure that you correct yourself.
How has Chris managed to get jobs working for some of these people who are the
best in the world despite no credentials at the time that he got the jobs and
how do you of course create apocalyptic barbecue is very important.
Question.
We'll get into that and a risk having the entire neighborhood burned down.
I don't recommend you do that.
Of course.
I would never suggest such a thing,
but the story makes for a good time and we're going to get into it.
So please enjoy this wide ranging conversation with Chris Young and we'll take
you from extreme aviation and world record goals to mathematics,
biochemistry and everything in between.
So fuck it.
I left myself with no out on this one.
Enjoy.
Christopher,
welcome to the show.
Thanks Tim.
Excited to be here.
Yeah,
man.
Cool.
It's been a not too,
too long since we've hung out.
I mean we saw each other in Seattle and uh,
that was sands.
Matt Mullenweg.
Yes.
I'm actually impress you remember any of that?
There was a bit of drinking,
well not to,
uh,
not to point fingers,
but I'd say whenever we hang out there's always some form of drinking.
This seems to sneak in.
It might be a chef thing,
might be a chef thing.
But before we get to the chef thing,
and I suppose this is related,
but you have a myriad of obsessions that that strikes me as interesting and
we're going to get to this.
But since we were talking about the drinking and Seattle one,
that particular incident that I thought was very telling of your personality and
kind of Hilarious was this dinner that we had for a few people who had won
prizes to be brought to Seattle to have this incredible dinner.
And there was a family with a bunch of kids and the mom was talking about making
smoothies.
And uh,
just as before we started recording,
I said,
you don't need to feel that.
You have to censor yourself.
Not that that's what you do anyway.
And I just remember after she had finished this,
like heartfelt,
a description of her,
her smoothies,
vegetable smoothies,
you said,
well,
you know,
vegetables are trying to kill you.
And you went into this diatribe about,
uh,
vegetables.
Can you elaborate on why,
why that is the case?
Sure.
Um,
so the,
the idea,
I think I probably said something to the effect of,
you know,
uh,
salads,
a silent killer,
which salads,
right?
Which is actually not originally my idea.
It's uh,
the,
the great food writer,
Jeffrey Steingarten had a,
had a brilliant article about this.
Um,
but anybody who has sort of a biology background,
this makes some intuitive sense.
It's just one of these things we don't stop to think about.
If you're a plant,
like you're not looking to get eaten.
Like that's not a good outcome for you.
Uh,
and so you,
you can't run.
So you do all sorts of things to evolve some protection against all these
predators running around trying to eat you.
So it turns out if you're stuck in the ground and you can't run,
you're going to evolve this really elaborate chemical weapons system that when a
pass or a disease or a critter basically starts to gnaw on your routes are non
your stocks or non your leaves,
none of which are the part that you want to have eaten,
you're going to try to poison them.
Um,
and so a whole bunch of things like fava beans,
you know,
if you eat them raw,
people die every year from eating too many raw fava beans.
Uh,
apple seeds have trace amounts of,
of cyanide,
not enough to be an issue for a human,
but for Pash.
Sure.
Even when a fruit bruises and it sort of turns that unsightly brown,
that's a cascading enzymatic chemical reaction designed to create a bunch of
molecular compounds that prevent spoilage.
So there's all these people that think eating raw vegetables is like this
inherently healthy,
somehow more pure act of eating.
And it's like,
no,
you're eating mostly a bunch of toxins and poisons and things that they may not
affect you because you're a pretty large mammal.
But mostly they're not that great for you.
Like spinach I think was the example I use that people think of pop by and that
you get all this iron from spinach.
Like it's part myth.
There's just not that much iron in spinach compared to many other plant foods.
But also raw spinach contains a ton of oxalic acid,
which actually binds iron.
So people eat a lot of raw spinach,
they end up with an iron deficiency.
And that's what produces that sort of a,
not cotton mouth feel.
But that's um,
you know,
Spanish is very mild in this.
But,
uh,
a sorrel,
which is a,
is a relative.
It has this,
this prickly,
uh,
if you've ever eaten rhubarb,
rhubarb is very high in it.
And if you raw rhubarb,
that hasn't been cooked down in a bunch of sugar with a bunch of jammy
strawberries,
um,
it's a pleasant vegetable,
but it's,
it's not as amazing as people think it is.
And it also can leave you with this cottony mouth,
especially if you'd at Rha,
which,
which I remember doing as a kid and it wasn't,
wasn't that great.
Now imagine in the same bucket you have,
uh,
now some of these might be from lagoons or otherwise,
but,
uh,
fight,
fighting acid and sapping pins and all these various kidney beans are another
thing where you really need to cook them in an actually your best throwing out
the water.
You Cook them in one,
you know,
you're gonna Fart a bunch less because you're basically diluting down a lot of
the illegal saccharides rides that you can't digest.
But also you're tending to a dispense with,
uh,
some of the more water soluble compounds that aren't very good for us.
So the science,
you bring a lot of science to the table.
Take me through getting to math and biochemistry.
Uh,
did that come before or after food and cooking?
It certainly came well before professionally doing it.
Um,
the cooking thing was something I always did as a kid.
It was just not the kind of thing that somebody growing up in the seventies and
eighties was like,
oh,
that's a good career choice.
Like,
no,
like growing up in the like aspirational,
middle,
middle class,
like becoming a chef was not a good career choice.
You were not encouraged in that direction.
And like late 1980s heartland America science I think was always interesting to
me.
Um,
it was stuff that I gravitated towards,
but it wasn't the kind of thing that I had a natural aptitude to be quite
honest.
Taking math for example,
um,
the highest grade I think I got in a mathematics class all the way up through
high school was a c minus I think partly because I had a chip on my shoulder
about it.
And,
and partly because mathematics as it existed at the university level,
once you got beyond like the weed out classes like that bear no resemblance to
what I had seen throughout high school and junior high and elementary school.
Uh,
and so I think I partly got the degree to be able to say,
see,
it really was the teacher's not me.
And partly because I actually discovered it was,
it was actually really elegant and fun and interesting because you were sort of
playing these mental games of like what would the world be like if volume no
longer has a physical meaning and stuff like that.
Uh,
so I sort of took university in a very indirect approach where I just took
things that were interesting to me or I took them because their particular
professor was teaching them and that that person was always interesting in doing
cool as shit.
It happened to be that like after seven years.
And I kind of looked around and said like,
what do I have enough to have a degree?
And it was like,
oh well I kind of have enough to have a degree in pure mathematics and I kind of
have enough to have a degree in biochemistry and I kind of have enough to sort
of have a degree in history.
And so I
maybe I should apply for those historical mathematical biochemistry,
something like that.
What was your first Gig out of college?
And it always strikes me when I'm having these conversations with friends.
It gives me an excuse to ask like the 20 questions.
It would seem utterly weird and creepy if I did it in like a normal conversation
over wine.
But I have no idea.
Like what was your first job out of college cook?
So how like that that happened,
how's that happen?
Um,
so this goes back to to,
you know,
the year 2000 and I was starting to pursue a phd and what I or what I hoped
would turn into a phd in an area called bio molecular structure and design.
So specifically it's sort of tied together mathematics and Physical Chemistry
and cancer research and computers in a,
in a whole bunch of stuff I was kind of sort of interested in.
Um,
but I also sort of,
I had like a whole bunch of chaos going on in my life with crazy girlfriends,
uh,
one in particular.
So like,
you know,
academically I was getting burned out and in the meantime,
my personal life was sort of cratering in a super awkward and painful kind of
way.
And I remember somewhere around September,
October,
2001,
so after September 11th,
I just remember like my life totally imploded,
like in the course of about a week where like things were going really poorly
for my research.
Um,
my,
the,
uh,
the principal investigator on the project it was at was really like,
just pleased with my work.
And part of that was I,
I'd made some bad choices about the project and part of it was like I was
completely distracted about what was imploding in my personal life.
And so it was just sort of one of these,
fuck it,
I'm going to walk away from it,
um,
with no clear idea of what the hell I'm going to do.
And I'd always cooked.
Like I enjoyed cooking and I was reading a bunch of,
uh,
I was actually cooking my way through the French laundry cookbook and I was
diving into Harold McGee,
both of which I discovered around that time in a while.
That's the science of cooking.
No,
yeah.
Uh,
the,
uh,
and food in cooking the science and lower of the kitchen on food.
And so like that book was fascinating to me.
It was just like,
this stuff is so awesome.
How did,
you know?
And I was one of those books I just discovered randomly browsing at Barnes and
noble and it was like find,
yeah,
it was just like this thing is cool.
And just as a quick pause for people who've seen the four hour chef video,
like the book trailer,
the movie trailer,
we shot it at chef steps,
which is in Seattle,
uh,
which,
which uh,
which Chris has is certainly a strong,
heavily involved with this.
At least we'll get into it.
But the placeholder that we used for the four hour chef book,
because we put it in in post production was Harold's book.
Harold's book.
Yup.
It's about the right size.
Yeah.
It was perfect science.
So like all of this stuff was going on and it was like,
I have no idea what I'm going to do.
I'm basically walking away from my,
from my,
my grant funding and like I've got to get my head back together because of a bad
relationship.
And so I just decided like I enjoy cooking so I'm going to get a job as a chef
while I figured out what the Hell I'm going to do with my life.
Like that was kind of as far as the master plan went at that point.
And so like I wrote letters to all of these chefs that had restaurants that as
far as I could tell were kind of important restaurants in Seattle with like my
academic CV being like,
I am looking for a job.
And remarkably like some of them actually called me back,
I think mostly to see,
like if I was having a laugh,
um,
which of my friends is pranking me,
basically,
it was like,
Ooh,
this ought to be good for a laugh.
And um,
it was,
uh,
it was a chef named Tim Kelly at the painted table who called me up on a Friday
and he was like,
I got your letter and you know,
now is not really a good time for you to come work for me at the painting table.
Like he quit the next day,
but I have this friend,
a bill Bilikiss he cooked for David Boulay.
He with your science background,
you and him would probably get on great.
You should call him up and tell him that I sent you and don't take no for a
fucking answer.
Just show up with your knives and start uh,
start cooking for him.
So like I called William Blake or something like a Tim Kelly said,
I should call you and definitely come work with you.
And I,
he's like,
this was a Friday.
He's like,
great,
when can you be here?
This was when I really realized like he just needed anyone who was willing to
work for free.
Um,
so I showed up at three o'clock with,
with like I had gotten a knife bag,
I had a couple of knives at that point they were like reasonably sharp and like
they immediately put me to work doing some really menial like pick a bunch of
time,
cut down some shard and like I apparently did it mostly right.
I was just incredibly slow and at the end of service,
like,
you know,
William was really gracious.
He sat down with me in the dining room.
He had a glass of wine,
he offered me a glass of wine and he's like,
you know,
now's probably not really a great time.
Not sure I have all the work for you.
And like being very earnest.
Um,
I was,
I was like,
I totally understand.
Is there anybody in town you'd recommend would be a good place for me to work?
I'm really,
I'm really like committed to doing this.
I really want to see what it's about.
And what I didn't realize at the time was like,
that was probably the perfect thing to have said to William because William had
an enormous ego and he was just not going to be capable of bringing himself to
say anybody else in town was any good at all.
And so he,
you could just see him sort of sputtering and well,
yeah.
Really,
there's no one like,
I think I'm probably the right person to teach you,
so why don't you come back on Tuesday and an accidental Jedi mind trick.
Yeah,
that was the,
that was the accidental Jedi mind trick.
And then it was just like,
I showed up and I kept showing up and like I didn't get paid for while,
so my credit card was getting obliterated.
But that's how I got into it.
And I discovered that professional cooking is really a mental illness.
You either have it or you don't.
And like within months I was like,
I have to do this.
There isn't really a choice.
And that we were off to the races you're gonna have.
That's like the coping mechanism.
That was totally my coping mechanism.
It like trip played into all of my introverted antisocial behaviors to basically
like lock myself up on a Friday and a Saturday and the kitchen because like,
I could feel like I was out and socializing,
but I didn't actually have to be out in socializing.
So it was great.
And like that,
the next eight years,
we're a cultural black hole for me.
So we're going to,
we're going to jump around as is my want to sort of create a podcast.
It's hard to follow as Momento.
Uh,
I want to talk about just paint,
paint a visual picture for people because we flash forward quite,
uh,
quite a,
quite a long ways.
Talk to me about the massive pigs rotating around a fire.
No,
it's fire rotating around a pig.
Can you explain the spectacle?
The people please just provide some and,
and how that came to be.
So,
uh,
I'll try to explain the spectacle and then I'll try to give the,
why do we do these shenanigans?
So essentially there's the concept of like rotating meet and usually you rotate
the animal in front of the fire and what you're doing is actually solving a very
pragmatic problem,
which is you have this big giant pig shaped object and the fire can bring heat
to the surface much,
much faster than that.
Heat can diffuse and percolate through the meat itself.
And every sort of weekend warrior bad cook has experienced this problem at some
point where like you char the outside and the inside is still raw,
black and blue.
And if you do something the size of a large animal,
like that phenomenon is exacerbated exponentially.
And so by rotating in at what you do is you bring a bunch of fire to one side
and it starts heating up and then before it overcooked you rotate it into the
shadows where it rests and the heat diffuses through an over sort of this dizzy
number of cycles.
You sort of time average the temperature.
So you get a crispy surface and an edge to edge evenly cooked animal.
And we call this like rotisserie.
It turns out the physics are totally symmetrical,
that you can rotate the animal in front of fire,
but you could also rotate the fire around the animal.
And aside from the idea that that's just sort of appealing on its own merits,
it actually solves some practical purposes that like by forcing wood or coal
around really,
really rapidly,
you're forcing a bunch of air through it and air drives the combustion faster.
And so the coals get hotter and the hotter they get,
the more intense like they glow.
And because you're dealing with radiant heat and radiant heat sort of goes by
the fourth power of the temperature.
The hotter you can get it,
like the more intense the seer and the more just radiate a radiant energy you're
dumping out and everybody gets a Suntan and it's just awesome.
And you're flinging coal everywhere and bits of fire and like dogs are hiding
and children are like running around and it,
it's this post apocalyptic wasteland,
kind of like Mad Max just came through and charged some animals.
So like,
why wouldn't you do this?
And is there a name for this?
What does a well,
so this was the inverted rotisserie spit.
Um,
and how much space does this,
well,
the first one,
which I think is the one you've seen some of the photos of had these two columns
that were eight feet tall stuffed with anthracite coal that we,
that's a whole story in itself of how you get anthracite coal.
And you know,
they were spinning around at about 36 RPM on a cement mixer base around a pig
that was sort of vertically suspended.
It had been spatchcocked in half and was vertically suspended.
And so it's sort of a great word.
That one his spatchcock yeah,
it's just flayed open on this sort of medieval like torture device and we're
spinning this fire around it at,
um,
kind of looks like a dissected pig.
Yeah.
I'm not a pig.
Well that's definitely,
it doesn't look a pig,
but dissect what's your frog like sort of split open and less flat and,
and you've got the fire rotating around it really rapidly.
Um,
that was actually my friend Neil Stevenson's backyard.
And this is the annual tradition and I'll come back cause there's the origin
story part to this.
So footnote,
yeah.
Later Reference Neal Stephenson of snow crash cryptonomic on Seveneves a whole
bunch of other stuff that I haven't read.
Yeah.
Um,
so if I read more of his stuff than you have,
I've only read one of his book and it's his most recent one because gliding
features in it and I'm the reason how it,
okay,
we'll come back to that.
So,
okay.
Can,
anyway,
that's also how I met Gabe Newell.
Um,
well this is the second time I met Gabe.
I'd Cook a dinner for gay,
but that was kind of it.
And Gay was at that party,
saw this spectacle and goes,
well that's fucking awesome.
So we totally need to do that at my house,
um,
for our Christmas solstice party.
But can you make it bigger?
And so for Gabes House,
we scaled it up.
Um,
two stories tall.
We had a chain of Hams and pineapples hanging off this,
uh,
this giant IBM and Gantry Crane and I think it was about 20 foot tall columns
that were spinning around this thing and that was called the tornado of fire.
So,
all right.
I've decided that this podcast is more like the movie snatch than Memento.
All right,
so like the cast of characters.
Uh,
so we have voiced the bullet dodged.
All right.
So Gabe Newell.
Yep.
Gabe is man of few words,
self made billionaire collection of thousands of knives.
I believe it.
It's an enormous collection.
I don't know how Mary,
we'll we'll get back to Gabe later because I want to leave that as a teaser.
So origin.
Yeah.
So I met Neal Stephenson,
uh,
when I was working with Nathan Myhrvold at his invention lab intellectual
ventures.
That's where we were writing modernist cuisine.
And Nathan had just founded a lab that was supposed to like invent cool shit.
And so like this Guy Neal Stephenson showed up who apparently is really famous,
but I had no idea who he was and I would like sit next to him.
And I remember coming by being like,
cause I was,
this was like the first book I was running,
I was trying to figure out how to be like a writer.
And so I remember coming up to him and be like,
I understand you're a writer or something.
He's like,
I understand you're a chef or something.
And that was kind of the basis for our friendship is like neither of us cared
about it.
I'm like our background.
And so,
but we did enjoy drinking a bunch of of English Ale and we,
I'd sit over at his house and,
and just chat with him.
And he had bought,
uh,
just had bought a new house.
It was like this sort of mock tutor mansion that sits on Lake Washington.
And every summer,
the first weekend in August in Seattle,
we have seafair weekend,
we're like,
it's fleet week and there's a bunch of jet boat races in the blue angels come
down.
And this basically all happens right over Neal's house.
And Neil's this very quiet,
introverted likes things,
very mellow kind of guy.
And he's like,
well,
since basically the entire neighborhood is going to be terrorized for a weekend,
we might as well just make a party out of that.
And so he,
he coined the idea of having an annual loudness fest and that year he was
redoing his backyard.
So it,
his backyard sorta looked like this,
looked like Beirut after like a,
a surgical airstrike had just happened to his yard.
So it wasn't like a big deal that we dug a six foot by six foot by six foot deep
pit in his backyard and turned it into a Jacuzzi to,
to,
to sue.
We'd cook a 300 pound pig and like each year after that for the next five years,
like each year had to be like more over the top,
more outlandish,
more ludicrously dangerous,
um,
dangerous in the sense of maybe the neighbor's houses will burn down.
Maybe somebody will be killed by spalling concrete.
Maybe somebody will just be burned as centers because like we're cooking with
magma.
Um,
that kind of thing.
Neil is a surprisingly fit dude.
I mean,
because you think writer,
you think entry but true,
true or false till actually,
no,
I'll let you tell the story.
So,
and I have to have him on the blog at some point,
but he does Victorian era exercises.
That is what I have.
He does that.
And he does,
uh,
various forms of what he calls Western martial arts involving sword fighting
where they really try to accurately recreate the way it was,
would have been done on what I understand is fairly limited information.
And so,
uh,
yeah know Neil I think takes physical fitness like absurdly seriously.
Um,
and so it,
it's,
it's one of the things that makes him like just awesome and interesting as a
person to hang around with.
Have you,
would think of him as this overly nerdy Scifi writer and like that's totally
true.
He's a huge nerd.
Um,
but he's also fascinated by all of these physical activities.
What did your path look like from the cooking job that you last described to
Heston Blumenthal?
That was a very,
very short hop,
um,
and a very lucky one.
But what is an appreciate is when I started working for Heston,
nobody had really heard of Heston.
Um,
so can you paint a picture of sure.
Test and maybe at that,
I dunno if it's today,
um,
you know,
Heston is a world famous chef and rightly so,
more famous outside of the u s I think that inside the u s but,
um,
he's arguably the most famous chef except for maybe Gordon Ramsey or Jamie
Oliver,
but certainly at that same level in the United Kingdom and Australia,
there would be no modernist cuisine without Heston.
There would be,
frankly no noma without Heston.
Heston was really the Oma considered the best Freshdesk the world on the day.
So,
you know,
there's this,
uh,
you know,
the fat duck is basically that restaurant between Elbulli in the early two
thousands and,
and noma a really starting in the,
in the,
in the last six or seven years.
In fact,
Renee went to through the fat duck kitchens and the El Bulli kitchens.
Um,
so the,
the path for me was,
was actually a pretty straight forward,
I think after about nine months of cooking in Seattle,
it was a very small,
a high end restaurant.
Not terribly busy,
but it was small in the sense of very few people on staff.
There's about four or five of us.
And so the good news was like you had to do everything,
which is fantastic when you are trying to learn to be a cook because I had no
formal training.
It was like it was all on the job and in a bigger restaurant you,
you sort of compartmentalize down and you can spend a year just doing the same
stuff over and over.
Um,
it's like any startup.
Right,
right.
And so,
you know,
by being a small,
a small restaurant that was just trying to stay afloat,
like you did everything and there wasn't time to think of,
for anyone to think about whether you should be doing that.
But by the end of nine or maybe 10 months,
I had realized I was really not going to learn anything more.
Here I,
I'd sort of maxed out the learning curve and around that time my goal,
you know,
you'd maxed out the learning curve.
What were the symptoms of that boredom?
I think on a certain level of I was doing,
I was finding myself repetitive.
I was finding like I'd set little tasks for myself at that time,
like if it was shallots,
um,
and I had to get through a bunch of Bruin and had to get a box of five very fine
dice.
If I had to get that done,
I would try to time it.
It,
you know,
be able to do a shallot is flawless as I could and say 10 seconds,
a salad or a whole box in 15 minutes or,
and I realized like those games weren't really that interested anymore because I
wasn't able to advance and it was about as fast as I was going to get.
Um,
or I was repeating them over and over and there weren't new challenges.
and I also found myself struggling with,
with,
uh,
with William because I was wanting to push to do more or to try new things on
the menu.
And you know,
he was really pushing back in,
in retrospect,
I realized those were the,
those were actually just the limits of that business.
They couldn't take more on,
they couldn't afford to do necessarily more ambitious things.
Um,
you know,
his job was to keep the lights on and make sure he was,
was balancing the bills.
And that's a very,
really hard challenge in any restaurant.
And so that was sort of,
to me,
the signal of I need to move on somewhere.
There was a bunch of other stuff going on.
I think in the background of I,
I'd gotten a book from Michelle Brock called essential cuisine that came out
that year and in English essential essential cuisine,
Michel Bra,
who was a three star chef in Europe.
And I think if you talked to a lot of chefs that came up in the early two
thousands will all point to that,
especially at the high end.
We'll all point to that book is being like,
Holy Fuck,
what was this like?
Nobody had seen Phil the last be Ras,
the Ras,
and you just,
I remember looking at it being like,
I don't know anybody in Seattle doing food that looks anything.
I don't know if anybody anywhere doing food that looks like this,
you know?
And I thought about wanting to go cook at that restaurant,
but a,
I didn't think I was remotely good enough.
And B,
I didn't speak any French so that wasn't going to make it any easier.
But it had me thinking about I needed to move on,
I needed to see more and I knew I wasn't seeing this,
this kind of stuff here and,
and,
and so how did I know it was time to leave there was realizing that I wasn't
really getting any better learning new skills in the restaurant,
but also because I was like all of my disposable income was going into buying
more cookbooks.
I was realizing what I wasn't seeing.
You're seeing the give me the big,
the big hedge on text of the world.
And so about that time for Christmas,
actually my girlfriend,
her mother gave me an anthology of food writing in 2002 and there was an article
and it called the gastro naughts and it was talking about this conference in
Italy that chefs and scientists got together and we're collaborating to try to
invent the future of cooking.
And in particular,
they had Harold McGee talking about the chef with a name that nobody had heard
of from England called Heston Blumenthal,
who is really trying to apply science in his kitchen to do better food,
to do more delicious food,
to understand the why's of cooking.
And I was like that,
that sounds perfect.
So I wrote a letter,
I mean,
is,
is sort of antiquated as it sounds.
I wrote a letter and I,
and I,
um,
I actually faxed it to them,
and said like,
I've heard about your restaurant.
I'm a,
I'm a chef cooking in Seattle.
I'd love to come over to eat and stodge uh,
basically apprentice for the weekend in your kitchen,
just just to see.
And they said,
sure.
Um,
so I flew myself over shortly after Valentine's Day,
2003 is it typical that a restaurant just says sure.
To request list that actually surprisingly common if you ask in the right way.
Now,
if you go to a restaurant that's oversubscribed,
if you go to like the hottest restaurant,
there's a line of people they can choose from and they're going to choose the
best because that's their recruiting ground.
Um,
but in retrospect,
I don't even think it's a good decision as a chef to go there unless you're
already established.
Because by the time a restaurant gets that famous where there's a line of stodgy
shares out the door,
it's a machine.
It has to be,
everybody's coming,
they're expecting to get the greatest hits,
get the experience.
And so it's very risky for a restaurant to basically allow a stodge here.
Much freedom at all the,
so what turned out to be perfect was the fat duck had just become a two.
I actually thought it was a one star when I apply,
but it had just gotten it second star.
I don't know that I would've had the guts to apply if I'd known they were a two
star and they,
you know,
they didn't have that many customers.
And so I didn't really feel like I was overreaching.
And that was the bit of luck.
Is it,
it turned out this was about to become one of the best restaurants in the world.
It was a,
there was some dumb luck and timing here,
but to sort of finish the story,
I flew myself over by myself cause that was all I could afford.
And I remember being very confused about like the geography of England because
the fat duck is actually west of London Heathrow near a town called Maidenhead.
It's,
it's actually a tiny little town in the Thames River called Bray.
Uh,
so I booked myself in a hotel and like west London stupidly,
and I'm like jet lag and I get to the hotel and they check in and then by that
time I need to drive right out to the,
to the restaurant.
And this is like my first experience driving on the wrong side of the road.
And,
uh,
I think the statute of limitations,
right?
Because I also had to drive myself back that night after a lot of wine.
And that also inadvisable it advisable in the wheel,
did not look better for it.
Um,
but I got out to the restaurant and I see they sat me at a table of one under a
stairwell and the restaurant is the 600 year old pub.
The ceilings are about seven feet tall,
very unassuming,
not what you'd expect for this,
this,
this finite room.
It was like you're in someone's living room.
And I think the best way I could describe the meal that night starts with the,
the,
the dish that it actually starts with to this day.
The first issue get is the liquid nitrogen poach green tea sour.
And so I'm sitting at this very minimalist white linen table.
Nothing else is sitting on it.
And before they take your order,
before anything else,
the waiter wheels over a year,
a don one of those trolleys up to your table has a cauldron,
a technically a dewar ball of liquid nitrogen boiling away at 200 degrees below
zero Celsius.
And he picks up,
uh,
a whipping siphon,
um,
and dispense has what looks like a dollop of shaving mousse onto the end of a
spoon and then knocks it into that,
that cauldron of liquid nitrogen.
And turns it over and base it for exactly eight seconds and then strains it out
and dust it with some green tea,
matcha powder and hands it over to you on a little,
a little a chilled plate and asked you to pick it up and eat it all in one bite.
And it looks like this little Marangu and when you bite into it,
or at least for me,
I was just fantastic that the shell sort of shatters crisply like glass and then
it gives away this,
this luscious moose that's racing with the acidity of lime juice and the
astringency of a bit of green tea.
But the coolest part is you get this puff of smoke out your nose,
so you look like a smoking dragon.
There's a video of,
of me experiencing that for the first time in your lab.
Yes.
Uh,
if you search Tim Ferriss chef steps,
I'm sure it'll pop up somewhere.
And so like it sort of,
you know,
twist your mind like what is this?
But you know,
the purpose was actually,
it turned out totally reasoned out.
It was,
if you've ever had orange juice in the morning after brushing your teeth,
it tastes awful.
And it's not because the orange juice changes because your mouth changed.
And and flavor is this idea that's actually constructed by your brain from all
these sensory inputs.
And so if you take orange juice and you,
which is acidic and you drink it after you've had a mouthful of alkaline
toothpaste,
it neutralizes that acidity.
It tastes awful.
And if you're trying to be the best wrestler in the world,
you kind of want a level playing field.
So the lime juice in that green tea sour is designed to neutralize any
toothpastes residue.
And the green tea provides these astringent polyphenols to clean it,
cleanse all the soft tissue because maybe you had a cigarette,
maybe you had a packet of chips or something before you came to the restaurant.
So it's basically mouthwash that's this surprising entertaining delight and the
rest of the meal,
like totally did my head in and just blew me away because not only was
everything whimsical and fun and gorgeous to look at,
but everything was delicious.
And so at the end of that night,
I walked back in there,
I was like,
I will work for free for as long as you will let me work here.
And what I didn't know is at the time they had no money where they were going
bankrupt and so they,
they were like sure.
You said the magic words.
Yes.
So I got back to the hotel that night and I called my girlfriend back in radio
APP.
Exactly.
I said,
great news,
Dawn.
Um,
I've just accepted a job at the fat duck.
I'm coming home and a couple of days I need to pack and I'm back here in a month
and all I got was,
I can't talk about this right now.
Click.
Um,
and she's my wife now,
so it didn't work out that badly.
But you can kind of imagine how the wind,
she's high tolerance,
high built in tolerance for,
for Chris Young traits,
I guess.
Uh,
it's a,
it's a job requirement.
Uh,
what,
what do you learn at the fat duck or from Heston?
Everything Heston Heston really became,
my mentor is as a chef.
I worked for him for five years.
Um,
I initially worked for him as an unpaid stodge air and this was like back in the
day when some of the chefs were like just out of prison and things like that and
uh,
it was transitional.
Like we are moving.
Definitely most of the chefs were way above,
above that,
but there was a few chefs that were still flaky and so I remember literally a
chef just,
they'd hired him and he didn't show up for work and they're like,
somebody has got to be on that station,
so congratulations.
You're,
you're running that section now.
And that was like getting promoted for me like I am,
it was at that time,
like at best sort of a farm team getting promoted to the majors.
It's like have fun.
I got my ass handed to me every day for the next three months.
I remember I was the first to arrive at the restaurant at six 30 in the morning
or seven it depending on the day and the wait staff,
the chefs had all left the kitchen.
The wait staff was having to throw me out at the end of the night because I was
trying to get ahead of my prep,
not because like I was like this really diligent guy,
but because I needed every bit of extra time because I sucked compared to
everyone else.
I didn't know how to be fast enough yet.
I didn't know how to organize my Misa applause list to do things these and plus
getting everything,
getting everything in the right place.
You have this cramped,
ginormous clipboard of all the things you have to get done that day.
And if you don't put that puzzle in just the right order,
you're not going to get the job done in time.
And then you're going to have,
you're going to go down bad and potentially pull everybody else down with you.
And so you will be hated.
Um,
and so it was like,
I didn't want to be like that.
Hated you.
Don't want to be the private,
like I was already the American,
so I was already at a total disadvantage.
You don't want to be the private pile from full metal jacket.
Totally that.
And so like it was put in the extra effort.
But that's one of the things I really learned was
people see that and if you are busting your ass and if you're not slacking and
if you're just not totally incompetent,
people are going to build you up.
At least if you're in a good place,
if you're not in that kind of place,
you should probably leave.
Um,
but people built me up over time and by the end of those three months,
Heston,
I had not become anything close to the best line cook.
Not even,
not even at the same caliber,
but I did have a knack for solving problems that nobody else could solve.
And that's when Heston was like,
you know,
I've always wanted to have a kitchen that works on the new ideas.
I've always wanted to have a place that's away from the pressures of service,
where we develop the things we experiment,
where we can afford to fail without affecting the customers.
And with your science background,
why don't you move to England fulltime Chris and build that up.
And that was,
that was my opportunity.
So it was like walk through that door,
right?
This wasn't that hard.
What types of problems were you able to solve?
Well that led him to,
so there were,
there are two things.
So one was our stock,
um,
we made an unbelievable number of different stock and Heston was kind of this no
holds barred.
We're going to go for the last point,
1% of perfection on everything.
And stocks come from meat and meat is really expensive.
And we were doing things like roasting down entire legs of animals to canteen
off the juices as they accumulated,
create these unbelievable decadent,
rich,
a Jew to go with the,
the Vera for the various sauces.
And not only was that time consuming and labor intensive,
but like it was ludicrously expensive,
like just totally insane.
Like you could take to talk to most Michelin Star chefs and they'd be like,
that's crazy talk.
Like nobody does that.
Well we did.
And I remember being like,
what would that,
so just just to,
just to try to put a fine point that it's,
when you say absurdly expensive,
like what do we w w would,
uh,
something like that look like,
oh,
thousands of pounds a week for a restaurant that really couldn't afford to be
doing that because we didn't have enough customers.
Got It.
Even if you did have enough customers,
it's still nuts because you don't have that kind of margin do that.
But we did,
uh,
like because it was better,
like we would do it and I remember we would serve the pieces of meat for family
meal and guess what?
Like the lamb still tasted like lamb and the beef still tasted like beef and,
and the veal still tasted like veal.
And like my chemist brain kicks in is like,
we haven't gotten everything out.
Like,
as nice as it is to have like the lamb stew,
uh,
for,
for staff meal,
which,
which made the Irish contingent happy.
Like that's not a good thing for the restaurant.
And so I was like,
you know,
I think we can do a better job here by grinding the meat up to increase the
surface area to volume and let's use a pressure cooker because increase the
temperature,
we can extract more.
And so I did a bunch of experiments like in between service and I was creating
some of the stocks that Heston was like these rival anything we're doing and I'm
doing it with a fraction of the meet.
So as a restaurant we ended up buying a $36,000 pressure Brat Pan that was like
big giant scale,
a commercial,
a pressure cooker and are a chef that just did that full time for all our stocks
and sauces.
And we paid it back I think within the first six months in terms of the savings.
And we shifted all of the production over.
So like that was one thing that was a very process or anything.
It was very transparent to the customers.
But about the same time,
Heston was starting to spend time with front Adrion Albert Adria from Elbulli
and they were just starting to do something they would become famous for.
And about a year,
these caviar,
um,
these little edible caviar that they were making from Mellon and the way they
were doing it as they were taking a seaweed based hydrocolloid,
technically algenate and they were mixing that,
that hydrocolloid into melon juice,
dripping it into a calcium back that caused it to set up.
And it was like little folk caviar that tasted like melon.
And so this I think went on the 2004 Elbulli menu and Heston to seen it and they
were very secretive about it.
Like,
well you take product x and you mix it with product y and this is what you get.
So Heston came back,
he was like,
you know,
how is that done?
And I sort of reverse engineered it and figured it out.
And so those were the kinds of little things that I started kind of getting it
reputation for even though I was like in many other regards,
like nowhere near the caliber of the other chefs in terms of like raw technical,
a Rah Rah cooking abilities.
And so that Kinda gave me my opening.
Now you,
you are one of only a few friends that I enjoy asking seemingly innocuous
questions of because I get pretty much the same pattern and,
and I see this,
uh,
with you.
I see it with a number of friends,
like Matt Mullenweg,
another mutual friend.
And then we have,
uh,
Eric Cressey who does trains a lot of professional baseball players and whatnot.
If I ask him about deadlifts or any type of tear I might have on the inside of
my leg.
So I just want to,
I'm not going to read the whole thing because it's like a mini novella.
But this is usually how it works is I'll,
I'll send you a text and it will be something like,
Hey,
if I wanted to cool down the water in my bath tub to 50 degrees Fahrenheit or 45
degrees,
I'm looking at this,
this and this option,
what would you do?
And usually the response is along the lines of,
let me think about that.
I might think about a or B.
And then I remember it went radio silent and then day later I got this email,
ice baths and such as the subject line and I'm just going to read part of it.
So I did a little bit of thinking about this and some quick math to confirm my
intuition.
Tldr by a small ice maker,
he didn't clean water as a pain because the water has the highest specific heat
amount of energy required to change the temperature of one gram by one degree
Celsius of any common substance.
Your bathtub holds something like 50 gallons.
Assuming you're cold tap water,
it comes out at 50 degrees Fahrenheit and you would like about that 40 degrees
Fahrenheit.
Then you need to pull about 4.4 4 million joules of heat energy out of the water
to drop the temperature.
Adding ice is by far the fastest,
most efficient way to do the job without resorting to any kind of nonsense.
Direct injection of liquid nitrogen would be fun.
29 pounds of ice would,
you should do the job nicely.
Better yet,
if the ice is cubed,
it'll melt quickly and chill your bath within 10 minutes or so.
Kind of the similar surface area approach that you would use for the uh,
the joke.
You could go high tech and get an immersion Schiller of some kind.
They'll do the job eventually,
but it's going to take a wall.
Then this is,
this is the part that I like and just goes on and on.
Your typical domestic electrical outlet is limited to 15 amps,
which works out to about 1800 watts of power.
Drawing any more in the fuse is going to blow physics being the bitch that it
is.
Immersion chillers only about 40% energy efficient at best.
This means that even a $4,000 1800 watt laboratory,
it goes on and on and on and on.
So have you always had this degree of OCD doc?
Nauseousness I like it because you've harnessed it for the,
for powers of good.
Uh,
and let me know I'm not working on evil.
That's true.
Well I not,
not usually a forces of evil and I'm going to retrieve,
I have uh,
a Yak milk bone that my dog is chewing and making a lot of noise with Molly.
I'll give you one of these later.
Uh,
so I'm going to retrieve that.
But has this,
has this been a trait present since you were a little kid or,
or when did that start?
I think on some level,
yeah,
I,
I am terrible at things that I am not interested in if I'm interested in it.
It's one of these things where I will devote almost all my tie,
no completely obsess about it.
And I actually don't have a very good off switch,
which can make me pretty difficult to deal with sometimes.
And as I think back,
like in elementary school,
junior high,
high school things that I was interested about in like high school was a great
example.
It was super into desktop publishing in Zenes and like,
like reading Ray Gun and early early issues of wired and be like,
I want to do stuff like that.
Like I obsessed about it and learned everything about it and knew who was doing
what.
But like math at the time who gives a rat's ass and like,
even though it was like super bad for my college admissions process,
like that didn't motivate me.
So I think I've always had the,
I like to obsess on stuff where I can just keep going deeper and deeper and,
and on some level mastering or at least understanding what mastery is about in
that,
in that area.
But it's totally driven by whatever's interesting me at that time.
How did you get converted to being interested in math?
Like it was at a particular teacher?
Yeah,
I think it was a combination of that.
So I was briefly at the University of Vermont.
It's not where I finished my degree,
but I started there mostly because it was very far from New Mexico where a Wa
where high school was and I wanted to get the hell out.
And um,
also because their admissions policy was basically,
do you have a for an out of state,
like do you have a pulse?
Like can you pay out of state tuition?
Yeah.
So,
okay,
welcome.
I took a a whole bunch of classes but somehow I ended up signing up for calculus
one,
which was like in retrospect,
like totally insane.
There was no reason to believe that was a good choice at all.
But there was a particularly good,
uh,
it was actually a Grad student teaching it and somehow it made sense.
A lot of it was a lot of its thinking.
Uh,
you know,
calculus is often about a can be thought of in terms of the math of motion and
stuff.
And so I found I had this knack for being able to think things through and
visualize stuff very well in terms of the movement or process or I can
manipulate three dimensional objects really well in my head.
Um,
and that like at that,
that naturally makes you like,
well qualified for Calculus.
But somehow that my unique background made it work for me and I was,
I just remember being shocked.
Like I got an a,
which was like super weird.
I was like,
wow,
I have no idea how he did that.
But it was enough that I kind of wanted to keep going.
And the further I got in it,
the more interesting it got.
And the more I discovered there was really interesting creative problems that I
could solve with those kinds of tools.
And now it started to make sense for me.
It's like it wasn't for its own sake,
it was the fact that Oh,
these are tools that allow me to solve and do these other interesting things.
And so it was like,
okay,
I want to learn this because I want to be able to do those kinds of things.
And this is like the stuff you need to know to be able to go do that.
What books,
if any,
have you gifted the most to other people?
So I think a lot of them will probably be in the cooking space.
I've definitely maybe on food and cooking.
I have gifted that a lot there.
I mean my career starts with that book in many ways.
And um,
uh,
you know,
there would be,
there wouldn't be any of this modern cooking movement without Harold's book.
I don't think.
And there's certainly wouldn't be modernist cuisine that,
that made a big,
uh,
made a big role in my career without that book.
So I've gifted a lot because I think it's relevant and I think for a certain
type of individual,
it's this kind of book that every time you open it up,
you see something,
you're like,
oh,
I didn't even know that was there.
That's super cool.
And,
and you read something and go,
well,
that's the world's like way more interesting than I thought.
Um,
I think I've gifted a Michel Bras essential cuisine quite a bit,
although it's hard to do now because I think it's out of print in English and
quite expensive.
The other book I've found myself gifting a lot lately is a out of print book on
thermodynamics called the second law and it was written by uh,
an Oxford physical chemistry professor named uh,
PW Atkins.
And that book is just a phenomenal casual infographic in read on how the world
works from an energy perspective.
And I've found that so incredibly useful in trying to understand how to do
something,
how to make something work,
whether something that's even possible.
It's frequently my bullshit detector when somebody's trying to convince me some
technology or some idea has merit.
I very quickly come back to just sketching out the kind of thing I did for that
email where it's like,
let me just see with knowing nothing about the subject,
if I can just sketch out the basic ideas of the energy of how much energy is
going to be involved or,
or like if I assume limitless capacities,
does this make any sense?
Ever.
And so many things that sound good,
like just don't pass muster.
As soon as you start looking at the world that way,
you're like,
well that's clearly just a waste of everybody's time and we should just stop and
go do this,
this thing over here.
Which like at least you're not having to invent new physics or violate the laws
of physics to go do it.
How much mathematics background do you need or physics background do you need
for that book to be readable?
None.
Great.
You know,
like you've got to be interested in curious in it.
So some people's eyes will glaze over,
but it's meant to be a popular site.
Like I did like the hardcore math laden,
um,
physical chemistry,
but uh,
very like I have to go look up the math for some of that stuff now.
Very,
I'm very rarely doing math.
That's much fancier than like division.
It's the concepts in just basically saying like,
okay,
like energy's got to be conserved.
Or efficiency is like,
what is the maximum theoretical efficiency this could ever work at?
So it is like the idea of a 100 mile per gallon car even make sense on the face
of it.
It's like,
no,
that's never going to happen unless we get rid of air.
Um,
so those kinds of things,
you don't actually need that much fancy math,
but it's useful just to have the concepts of thinking about this as how this
weird thing we call energy actually works and what's possible in this world and
what's not possible.
Do you read any fiction?
I do though.
It comes in and goes in phases.
So like I think most recently I read Neil Stevenson's Seveneves and like mostly
because,
uh,
I made a very,
very minor contribution to a sub theme in that book.
And I found like,
I actually enjoyed that a lot,
but mostly because it was like competence porn.
Uh,
what does that mean?
So Neil likes to go on these big rats on a,
about how some aspect of technology works.
And if you know Neil,
it's usually because like he fell into that hole and dug pretty deep and then
came back with all that because he knew all these experts with this
understanding.
And so he'll go on for pages and pages and pages explaining like how you would
actually attach nuclear reactor to a comment and you're like,
it's basically engineering porn.
It's like,
oh this is how you would do it.
So like if I'm ever in that situation,
now I know.
Well yeah he did that in a coop denomic on with some of the tunneling passages.
Right?
And which I loved because I think you and I and a lot of our mutual friends are
hardwired to get a crack hit from that type of detail.
We,
we like knowing how to do something and get stuff done.
Because I suppose at some of what I liked about cooking and what I like about
engineering and the types of stuff I do now,
you're like changing the world.
You're making something happen and it's not very abstract.
Like it's very concrete.
And that's for like my brain somehow that like that's just really satisfying.
And so books that tap into that competence porn.
I was looking at,
uh,
the Facebook feed of,
I got him,
Alex Honnold.
So he,
I interviewed him for the podcast.
I'm not sure if it will have been published yet when people hear this probably.
So he's the most famous free solo climber in the world and has many,
many speed records.
Uh,
and uh,
there was a post he put up about stress and anxiety and the point he makes is
one of the things I love about climbing and being in the mountains,
it's an immediate return environment.
You make decisions,
you have an impact,
you reevaluate,
you make more decisions,
et cetera.
In other words,
the sort of delayed return environment being tied to anxiety.
So it,
it strikes me that
uh,
on a very human level it would be fulfilling
to have that type of immediate feedback and ability to iterate that you have an
engineering or cooking.
I,
I tend to gravitate towards things where
it's,
it's actually weird,
like the day to day provides very tangible feedback.
The goals can actually take years to accomplish,
but I find it don't have the staying power for projects where there isn't a
fairly fast feedback loop running on some level that tells me if I'm even going
in a good direction.
Um,
if it's just totally ambiguous or,
or you just can't know,
uh,
I really struggle with that.
That's hard.
See,
you talked about writing the letter to Hesston,
uh,
and then your Jedi mind trick on the gent earlier.
You've also worked with Nathan Myhrvold as we mentioned,
uh,
later directly with Bill Gates.
How do you end up working for these people?
I mean,
if you had to try to tidy other,
some kind of pattern,
is there one?
Well,
so food,
um,
definitely ties together.
I mean it quite explicitly.
I met Nathan because he was a guest at the fat duck and uh,
Seattle is home for him and Seattle was kind of sort of home for me before the
fat duck guy,
I w I ended up going to university of Washington.
That's where I did my degrees and it's,
it was this home as anywhere.
So Nathan was fascinated by cooking.
He was particularly fascinated by the science behind cooking and that was a
shared passion and we struck up a friendship over that.
So who is Nathan for be blue on it?
Ah,
so Nathan has many things depending on who you ask.
But uh,
the definition I would give is,
uh,
Nathan was my coauthor on modernist cuisine.
Nathan was,
uh,
you know,
there would be no modernist cuisine without Nathan.
He's most famous I think for being the first chief technology officer of
Microsoft.
Um,
he's more controversial today for being the founder and CEO of intellectual
ventures.
Um,
and in mentioned company to saw a giant patent troll to others.
The,
uh,
I think the truth is somewhere much more in the middle.
And let's look
the lessons learned.
I mean,
you can pick and choose from whether it's Nathan,
Bill,
Gates,
Heston.
Are there any lessons or expressions that really stuck with you that come to
mind?
And I'll buy you some time just by giving a personal example.
Like I had a professor at Princeton who had a huge impact on me and there,
there were really only a few who did at that university despite the,
the abundance of riches that they have.
But uh,
Edge Shao,
Z,
s,
c h a u who,
who taught high tech entrepreneurship,
I believe he was the first one of the first computer science professors,
uh,
ever at Stanford.
Partially because just like that cook didn't show up effectively the same thing
happened.
And they're like,
can any of you guys teach?
What does this computer,
computer science,
we don't know that is,
who can teach us?
And he's like,
I'll teach it.
Sure.
And that's,
that's how I got the Gig.
And uh,
went on to take a number of companies public,
become a congressman.
He was a competitive figure skater,
like fascinating guy.
But at one point,
I remember I was trying to get into his class.
It was already full.
It was oversubscribed.
And I said,
I'll do anything.
I kind of sent the,
the similar letter,
but I,
it was a letter,
I sent him a letter.
I guess it was an email through some basic terminal that we had at the time.
And I said,
I'll do anything.
I'll clean the erasers and inbetween classes,
whatever it takes.
I just,
I'll sit on the floor,
don't even need a chair,
et cetera.
And at one point,
you know,
I actually did like clean up afterwards and he said to me,
he goes,
Tim,
he's like,
don't get too good at the menial stuff.
Yeah.
Keep doing it.
And I was like,
oh,
that's actually pretty profound.
So anyway,
I was,
yeah,
no,
that's,
there are definitely some.
So I've been really,
really lucky.
It's more intentional now than it was then.
But to have ended up with some profound mentors in my life,
um,
my father was,
was absolutely my first one.
Um,
I grew up in a family business.
I think,
you know,
today that gives,
like,
I am so glad for having had a lot of visibility into that at a young age because
now like I need to do that.
Um,
and everyone's looking to me for that.
So what was the business?
Oh,
his was advertising research.
Um,
and,
uh,
that,
you know,
that also has,
has proved fortuitous of just having really thought about how advertising
actually works.
Um,
how brands are built.
what's good advertising and what's bad to advertising,
how marketing has put together these kinds of things.
Um,
that's like enormously practical when you're running a company because it's a
big part of like your job.
Even if you're not doing the work,
you,
if you're the CEO,
you need to have some sense of like what this is all about.
Um,
so that there was any other aspects.
My Dad was a mentor,
but certainly giving me visibility at a very young age and to just how he thinks
about running his business was helpful with Heston.
Were there any specifics that your dad gave you or any particular thing that he
showed you that stuck with you?
Uh,
I think there's two things.
So one,
I remember something he said to me,
I probably was a g a freshman or a sophomore in high school.
I would have been an Albuquerque,
New Mexico.
And I distinctly remember him saying,
you know,
not needing to worry about what I was going to do because the job I was going to
do hadn't even been invented yet.
That's a great thing to say.
And it's like totally true.
My career,
like there was never a job description for what I did.
I made it up and got some,
somebody agreed that that was a thing of the thing which I remember for like a
long time I was like super freaked out that people are going to realize like,
no,
wait,
this isn't a thing at all.
Why are we paying you?
Like we're just going to stop.
I'm like,
and you know,
the interesting jobs are the ones that you make up.
Um,
I think,
and that's something I certainly hope to instill in my son is like,
don't worry about what your job is going to do.
Things that you're interested in.
And if you do them really well,
you're going to find a way to temper them with,
with some good business opportunity.
And that was the other thing he taught me was at some point he,
for as much value as you're trying to create in the world,
you need to capture some of that value tube so that you can do more of that.
And you know,
I,
I suppose today I'm just trying to strive for that.
Um,
so he gave me a lot of freedom to,
uh,
you know,
it was absolutely,
he gave me the ability to take risks that seem totally nuts.
Like the fact that I,
I gave up,
what do most people look like giving up on nearly nine years of advanced
education,
um,
to go become a cook.
Like to most people,
like I had gone insane.
Like that made zero sense whatsoever.
Like,
you're going to throw away all your degrees,
your phd track to go be a cook.
Like what,
what the Hell is wrong with you?
And he's like,
go do it.
Like totally reasonable thing to go do.
There was never that judgment on the tee.
Also have an atypical career path.
Um,
somewhat.
Yeah.
Pretty Atypical.
I mean,
uh,
so like there's stories of my parents.
My parents met when my dad was in the peace corps and my mom was teaching in a
convent school in Grenada.
She was no longer a nun,
but you know,
jokes and sue here,
she'd been in none for seven years.
Um,
and of course like being a nun in Grenada,
not a bad gig.
So you know,
that was formative for him.
And you know,
he came from,
I mean I've literally seen the house he was born in,
which had a dirt floor.
Like he was the alien in the family who had a perfect sat,
which got him into university Chicago and a free ride.
And like,
you know,
I think he was always striving to make that pay off.
And interestingly,
he never really took the traditional path all the way to,
he founded his own business doing research for,
came out of the ad world.
And so he started doing research for fortune 100 brands globally and he founded
his business and Albuquerque,
New Mexico and made that work.
And it was only possible because by 1990,
you know,
a fax machine and a million miles a year on American Airlines made such a thing
possible.
But it worked and it gave us,
you know,
I wish that my mom working as a nurse paid the bills all the way through the 90s
and gave us the opportunity to take a few more risks,
um,
as,
as I got into college and beyond.
How did your mom respond?
Also supportive.
That was by my parents.
I think my parents had a pretty good sense of who I was and you know,
stubborn obs,
I think they knew that saying,
you know,
yeah.
Like I'm going to do it either way,
so they might as well be supportive of it because like,
I've got to go do this.
I think they kind of thought it would have been a phase.
I don't think they were.
Maybe it is just a really,
it could be.
Um,
um,
I'm nearly 40.
I had to grow up,
um,
pretty soon,
but they,
uh,
they actually were reasonably encouraging it,
but they're like,
you know,
you're going to learn a lot.
This will be interesting.
And I think what was really good and from their perspectives are good.
They couldn't help me in that area.
There wasn't like they could be supportive as parents.
Um,
they helped pay the credit card bill sometimes when it was getting outlandish
and I was totally burning a hole in the ground.
Um,
but beyond that they had no influence in whether I did well is that there was,
there was no net there,
there was no,
my parents had no influence in that world or couldn't pull any strings.
So it was all self earned,
which I think they felt was really good for me.
And I think it was,
I think it was like incredibly helpful to have those be your own achievements
and not welded.
My parents make this possible for me.
What are some of the lessons that,
uh,
that you took from,
or things you learned from Heston?
I mean any specific instances?
A few things,
but the,
the biggest thing by far was Heston taught me what the standard of excellence
really is.
He always was pushing for the,
the last bit of,
of,
of effort,
always a saying,
no,
we can move the goalpost,
we can do better.
And he kept raising the bar on the team,
on the recipes,
on everything.
And it was never,
he wasn't,
by the time I got there,
I'd heard in the early days,
uh,
you know,
there was,
there was quite a bit of a temper about it,
but by the time I got there,
he didn't yell.
Um,
and you know,
he signaled disappointment in other ways,
but he really pushed you,
the team,
everyone else to strive for excellence all the time.
How did he signaled disappointment and other way?
While I can,
I can give you my,
my one canonical example,
which was,
I remember I was on Garmin,
Jay,
I was doing,
sending out one of the Hedy,
explain what that is.
That's a,
it's the section called section in traditional kitchen parlance,
but I was responsible for sending out several of the first courses that people
got.
So the red cabbage Gazpacho,
the famous quail jelly with,
with,
uh,
truffle toast.
I'm forgetting now.
Some of the things that were on the section,
I would send out the pre desserts.
Um,
and there was a few things on the,
on the Allah cart menu that the fat duck had at the time because I had the deep
fryer,
I would have to do that pig's head terrain,
I would do the radish.
Uh,
and,
and some of these,
it was actually a plus prepare the stocks and a whole bunch of other stuff.
It was,
uh,
it was,
wasn't the most technically demanding section,
but is it Easton?
He was grand central station.
And so there was a beast of a job in that regard.
So I remember this would have been 2003,
early when I was actually still stodgy.
And it was before I had founded the fat tech experimental kitchen and had sort
of earned the right to,
to fuck up a little.
I sent out a quail jelly that was for Swania VIP guest and I'd remembered I'd
gotten the orders in early during the afternoon that we were going to have some
VIP days in and I needed to prepare some of our VIP versions of the Quail Jelly.
And so I prepared them.
But it was actually,
I didn't get to it in time,
so I think I probably started doing it like three in the afternoon for like a
seven 30 scene.
Well,
it hadn't set up.
So there's a,
the,
essentially the dish has a,
uh,
a pea puree very smooth on the bottom that that sets a little firm.
And then we set the cubes of truffle and a baby turnip into it.
And then there was an intense quail stock that's cat that poured over it and
allowed to set.
And then we put a langoustine cream on top and we chase them truffles and it's
served with a little tiny bit of toast with truffle butter on it,
black truffles and some radishes.
And the order came on for it.
And I saw that they weren't fully set up and I tried to float the langoustine
cream on top anyway and I sent them out to the past knowing that they,
they weren't perfect.
Those things came back like a boomerang.
Heston just came around the corner holding them in his hand and just goes,
Chris,
he's like looking at me and then he's looking at the dish and he's looking at me
and he's looking at the dish and just not a chance.
Puts it back.
And as you remember,
the withering look like if I ever did that again,
don't show up again.
Like,
and I remember the lesson because he's like,
we like,
we can do something else.
Like if it's not ready,
we're not going to send it out and just hope they don't notice that it's not
that good.
Like,
we'll fix it,
we'll do something else,
but don't try to slip by something that you know is below the standard.
And it was like,
you only need that lesson once that it's like,
that wasn't the standard.
And you know what the standard is,
hold the standard,
um,
you know,
ask for help.
Fix it.
Do whatever's necessary but,
but don't cheat.
That should be your tee shirt.
Hold the standard.
I don't know that I need to be encouraged and Kylie and that behavior.
Um,
because there's,
there's another side to it where you just become a tyrant about it.
You try to push a team too far,
you try to raise the standards too fast and then you just end up like you turned
into an asshole basically if you go too far.
So you're managing people now and what we'll get to that but just to,
just to give people maybe a foreshadowing or a taste of things to come.
This is something I struggle with a lot.
How do you manage that fine line?
Because I would like to think,
and I do think that I have very,
very high standards sometimes.
I think they're so exacting that they drive people insane.
And to the extent that in the publishing world I am considered a,
a problem author as they would say,
just because I don't,
if something comes to the version of my pass,
like,
okay,
we're going to put this on the cover or this on the back flap or this and this
and it's not to my standards.
I just,
I don't,
I cannot allow it.
Um,
but when I'm managing people,
I,
some people can handle it,
some people can't.
But I do think there's a lot of onus on me also to decide how far is too far and
how far is not enough.
How do you,
how do you think about managing that?
I think I'm still trying to think about it and figure it out.
Um,
on my good days I think I manage it okay.
On my bad days.
Like I sort of feel like I had a personal failure,
that I didn't manage it all that well.
Um,
when it's,
especially when it's in the context of you're trying to do something really hard
and you've got the whole company leveraged out on this working and you have as a
CEO or as,
as you,
in case of your personal brand,
you have total visibility into everything.
And so that's the first thing is I tried on a good day,
I will try to step back and say like,
what context does this person even have?
And if I have provided appropriate context,
if I approach,
if I provided appropriate context and they knew that context and they made a bad
decision,
it's an open question of whether you need to have a discussion of whether that
was a bad decision or,
you know,
actually it's a bad decision,
but given all the context they had,
maybe I would've made the same decision or I could have imagined somebody else.
Um,
so increasingly I tried to find myself thinking about what context and
visibility do I have and what do they have and do a,
am I basically being unfair because I'm operating from a greater set of
information,
right?
Um,
that's still like means I screw up more often than not because I have a strong
bias towards let's fix the problem right now.
And that also usually can be quite ham handed where all I'm really training them
to do is read my mind to try to guess what I want.
And that's not going to work very well in terms of how we run the company or the
types of products we need to do.
Where Aye
work with elite people.
I work with people who are experienced in among the very best at what they do
and I will do a much better job in the team,
will much do a better job if we can take the time to set context and to
basically,
if there's a problem,
say let's look at how we can solve that differently rather than me just saying
we're going to do x.
That said,
there are times where like you need to take the scissors away.
Um,
because we're all running really fast and like we do not need to impale
ourselves out of stupidity.
So it's a dynamic thing and I'm still trying to figure that out quite honestly.
So you're holding the standard holding oneself and others to a high standard.
That's one thing that you got from,
from Huston.
What else comes to mind?
Asking why?
Asking questions?
Um,
challenging,
perceived or conventional wisdom?
Uh,
I've never seen somebody as curious about him who could talk to just about
anyone else,
about whatever it was they did,
what they were an expert,
whether they were a psychologist or a sports trainer or an athlete or another
chef or uh,
uh,
some,
some food expert of some sort or,
or a writer.
He had this unbelievable ability to sort of ask them incredible questions and
then sort of process it through his brain to have ideas that like,
I literally couldn't imagine having ever had that idea.
And so I think that really put me on a path towards being,
just really being curious,
wanting to understand what all these things were about and then using those as
creative tools of how do I take those kinds of ideas and apply them in my world.
What are,
do any specific examples come to mind of,
uh,
a question he used?
A lot or just a particular commonly held assumption that,
that he tested and I am of course,
thinking of the TV show where he did this quite a bit,
uh,
which I I enjoyed tremendously.
We might chat about that,
but anything,
anything in particular come to mind?
I mean,
and,
and the reason I ask,
so I'll give just as context.
Uh,
so for instance,
there are questions that some people are very well known for.
Uh,
but these are,
these are quite public facing,
like Peter Teal,
right?
And you know,
what,
why can't you,
why can't you hit your 10 year goals in the next six months in to these kind of
absurd forcing function type questions,
uh,
in what is something,
and I'm paraphrasing here,
but like,
what is something that you believe that other people think is insane,
you know,
roughly that type of stuff.
Um,
question that I ask of experts very often is,
you know,
who is good at this?
Who shouldn't be.
Okay.
Who doesn't have the attributes say of like a Michael Phelps who nonetheless as
an incredible sweater,
whatever that might be.
Any,
any kind of long held truth that you saw him test or,
or questions that come to mind?
Well,
so there,
you know,
there's certain
me,
a lot of culinary Laura,
I know he challenged in that influenced the,
the techniques.
Um,
I think the more interesting things were,
I don't remember a specific question.
What I do remember what were two specific things where Heston was remarkable.
It asking people in different ways but getting to the same end result of like
what interesting thing are you working on?
Like why is that interesting to you?
What surprising about that is anybody else thinking about this?
He had just this unbelievable ability to do anything.
I can give a specific example.
Um,
there was a psychologist at Oxford,
Charles Spence that Heston had a conversation with who had done some interesting
sensory research on juxtaposing temperatures.
Like Charles had created this a little tool,
this little instrument that was basically like a,
like a radiator,
like a home radiator.
But uniquely what it did is it,
it was about hand sized and it would juxtapose hot and cold temperature right
next to each other.
And you would think that like,
oh,
you feel hot and cold kind of next to each other,
you sort of get warm.
Right?
But like under certain circumstances,
like no,
that's,
that's not what you get.
You get really weird sensations because the brain is not equipped to process
this contrast in temperature so closely placed together.
And that was like what Charles was doing research on somehow.
And so Heston dug into that.
Why is that interesting?
Why is that surprising?
And then what?
I don't know how he,
he did,
I think that's what makes him uniquely Heston was he came back with like,
oh well when that be really interesting.
If somehow we could,
we could do that in a dish.
What if,
what if we could juxtapose two temperatures together somehow in a drink?
And I remember him,
this was right when I started working on a,
a on new dishes nominally as the fat tech experimental kitchen.
Um,
in fact,
I don't even think we named it that yet.
I think it was just Chris did experiments in a,
in a little shed in the back garden of the restaurant.
I think that's what it was.
And that dish became,
it was one of these things,
I'm like,
Hey,
I have this idea that we could make a drink somehow that would put hot and cold
together.
Like go do something with that.
And like that was a super weird idea and I'm going to be like,
you know,
like,
do you mean layered like you know,
cold on bottom,
half the time he's like,
no,
no.
They have to be vertical.
Like they have to be vertically juxtapose on like,
how the hell am I supposed to,
like,
like what am I supposed to do with that?
But at the end result,
I actually developed hot and cold tea and using a technology called fluid gels.
And I juxtaposed uh,
uh,
hot Earl grey tea of first it was t and then has to came in and it's going to be
ice tea and it's going to be Earl grey tea.
And these are the flavor notes we need to get and this is,
and essentially I'd shown that we could,
we could basically put a divider and a cop and we could pour this hot liquid on
one time,
this cold liquid and the other and because of the unique properties of this
fluid gel,
I could pull the divider out and if you whisked it to the table in a few
minutes,
the person could sip it and all the t on the right side of their mouth would be
piping hot Earl grey tea and all the t on the left side of their mouth would be
ice cold and you'd get that effect.
You'd get this like your hair would kind of stand back up and like the side of
your face that had the cold liquid in it felt like as heavy as concrete and the
side of your face with the hot liquid just felt like it disappeared.
It's like a super weird effect.
So like perfect one or for like you're having a stroke but don't have the time.
Basically I have,
I have some fat dot cotton gold tea.
But it was just that thought process of you can have this conversation with a
psychologist and have this inspiration for a dish where I might have had that
same conversation and been like,
oh,
that's an interesting effect.
But like I di I w I don't think I would have drawn that path of here's the idea,
here's what we can do with that.
And he had this ability to talk to anyone in,
pull those ideas out in the little,
you know,
a lot of them failed.
A lot of them went nowhere,
but enough of them hit that.
You're like,
wow,
that's like actually super impressive.
Um,
I don't see anybody else doing that.
I see a lot of people copying.
I don't see a lot of people finding those original sources for inspiration and
doing something unique.
And I think that really stuck with me and it's something I strive for in my work
of,
you know,
how do we challenge that?
How do we question and,
and,
and do something that isn't copying,
that's novel.
And that's inventive.
Let's flash forward to chef steps.
How has shift steps changed over time and what are some of the novel decisions
that you've made?
And could you describe what it is?
So chef steps is a,
uh,
a cooking technology company.
Specifically we make kitchen hardware that is controlled with mobile devices,
but really the,
the way we think about it is we're building devices that allow us to augment
people's intuitions in the kitchen to make them more successful.
There's so many things in the kitchen where you're sort of thwarted in terms of
getting the outcome you want because the technology sucks.
So if you think about it,
like you use your oven and should I set the oven at three 50 or four 15?
Is it going to be an hour or is it going to be 30 minutes?
Um,
and like why does it work in this one of them,
but not in this other oven.
And the answer's like,
ovens totally suck as a technology.
You're not even controlling the variables that really matter and what really
sucks about them.
And frankly,
every other tool we have in the kitchen is that we have to translate our human
desires into engineering parameters that we don't necessarily understand.
Even though that's not what we care about.
We care about,
I want a great roast chicken to have with my family,
or I want to have this,
this unbelievable experience of 72 hour short rib or I want to cook some amazing
vegetables.
And it's like sort of mind blowing to me that technology sucks that bad in in
2016 so chef steps as a company that's trying to solve those problems and we
sort of realized that nobody else was going to do it.
So we were going to have to build a hardware,
we were going to have to do artificial intelligence work,
we were going to have to build mobile app,
we are going to have to combine it with content and we were going to have to
combine it with community because that was the only way we were gonna be able to
bring it to market because nobody else in the world knows how to sell a device
like this.
So like,
I don't know that we fully understood that in 2012,
but we sort of knew that we had to go on our own unique journey and we knew we
needed a lot of independence and not a lot of outside people telling us how
we're supposed to build a company.
And you know,
so I think Matt Mullenweg said it best when he,
you know,
we first got to know,
uh,
I first got to know him and he,
you know,
got to know a little bit about chefs and he's like,
chefs test makes no sense to me.
You know,
I,
I sort of felt like I was making progress when about a year and a half ago.
Man.
It's like,
well,
that makes half cents now.
Um,
I think in 2016 we now actually know how it makes sense and how we'll do the
other job of running a business,
of making sure we make money and we can keep growing.
But it was this wandering path towards if we create a place in a culture where
we can put people who are passionate about cooking and passionate about
technology and passionate about inventing the future,
but who,
who are disciplined and experience and have a track record of getting shit done
and we create a culture that doesn't fuck them up or put them under a bunch of
managers who don't know what the fuck they're doing,
then we can create a company that nobody else could build.
And that was really,
we've evolved over the,
over the years we started out mostly as a bunch of guys putting shit on Youtube
and now you know the beautiful videos,
that beautiful videos,
but like,
okay,
how are we going to monetize that?
Well we're not going to monetize the videos,
but they built us a community and that community steered us in the direction of
what are the types of problems we can solve.
And we sort of looked around and originally said,
well,
maybe we'll just do the software and let's see if we can get some hardware
companies that get this vision and could do the hardware side of things.
And that was just beating our head against a wall.
So we're like,
well screw it,
we're going to do the hardware to,
um,
there's a lot of Hubris along the way.
Well,
you know,
there's that fine line between the necessary,
uh,
irrational exuberance and confidence and needed to actually kind of step off the
cliff and build the wings on the way down and really good and Hubris that all
make you self implode.
The,
the question I had was Q stage left reappearance of Gabe Newell.
Yeah.
Uh,
how has he influenced the trajectory or you and the company and who,
who is he?
Maybe we could start,
well,
so Gabe Newell is the founder and I think he calls himself CEO,
managing director of something or other valve.
Um,
I mean to us,
gave just gay,
but what is valve valve is the biggest soft,
well,
so electric car,
I think electronic arts is actually the biggest software company,
but valve essentially is by far the most unique company in the video game space.
A string of huge hits that redefined what video games could be.
They then basically realize they needed a better way of distributing games to
get there,
get control of their intellectual property back from like publishers,
uh,
in,
in the early two thousands.
And they built steam.
And steam is I believe,
the biggest online marketplace for video games.
And that's what's really made valve a,
a force to be reckoned with.
So it was like the iTunes of yoga.
It was really the iTunes before there was an iTunes for video games.
Um,
but valve was really a company that has gamers at its heart and focuses on
solving problems for,
for video gamers or people that create video games.
And they built an,
uh,
an entirely private,
um,
unbelievable business.
Um,
that has some very unorthodox ways of operating where,
you know,
nobody's your boss,
nobody tells you what to work on,
you've got to figure that out for yourself and,
and sort of self organize.
Um,
and now they're doing unbelievable work in the hardware space,
particularly in virtual reality with uh,
the HTC vive,
which was really technology developed by valve.
And so I think what Gabe did for us,
aside from being incredibly hands off,
was two things.
One,
um,
he gave us access to capital and a very unusual way that allowed us to be in
control of our own destiny.
And he did very,
very little beyond that except occasionally asking us questions about what types
of problems we are solving,
how we might think about a certain problem,
but this would be very,
very general.
Um,
and based on the types of things we would feed back of we're thinking about this
or we're trying to solve this problem,
he kind of made a decision of whether he was going to keep extending a capital.
And we've kind of,
he's kind of gone on this journey with us,
but we see Gabe in a business capacity once or twice a year,
we usually have a talk for 15,
20 minutes and he might ask a question like,
how are you thinking about hiring people?
Like,
how do you hire people?
Or how do you interview people?
Or like,
what's the role of content creators in the kitchen?
Like how does that work?
And he'll just ask questions.
Like in the early days it would totally randomize us.
We'd be like,
does gave mean like we should be doing virtual reality for the kitchen?
Like,
no,
he didn't mean that.
It's usually whatever he's thinking about.
And he's just kind of seeing like,
how is our team thinking about this?
What are the types of problems we're solving?
And,
you know,
do they make sense to him?
Can you talk about the unusual way in which he's giving you capital or is that
not something I can simply say he's a,
you know,
he's described himself as acting as a bank.
Gabe does not own any of chef steps.
Um,
he does not control how we run the company.
Chef steps is 100% owned by chef steps.
Um,
he's made it possible for us to,
to make some pretty big bets,
but he's also basically made it po,
you know,
kept us hungry.
So essentially he's,
he's provided us a very,
very favorable loan that we're welcome to payback when,
whenever we want.
And that,
uh,
doesn't have any terms that sort of turned it into,
I'm secretly going to control your company.
Like I think it was always clear you guys have to own your work.
So Gabe has infinite levels of opportunities in front of them.
So why,
why would he,
why would he take the,
the time,
energy,
just bandwidth to do that?
So I really wish there was like some super awesome answer I could give you here.
I will tell you how I know gave and how this all went down.
I first met Gabe because I auctioned off a Denver that I would,
I would cook at a whole dinner.
Yeah.
I auctioned off at dinner at a charity called friends of the children and gave
his wife Lisa,
uh,
purchase that dinner.
And uh,
so myself and a couple of colleagues from modernist cuisine at the time,
cause that's where I was working then,
uh,
we could get dinner at house and like apparently the dinner according to gave
the dinner was awesome and fun and we had liquid nitrogen and he's like,
this is like the one of the best dining experiences I've ever had.
And I know a lot of people in the world of food and lots of things.
I don't know anybody that talks and thinks about food the way you guys do.
And as he said,
like,
that was kind of like,
I didn't see gay for a very long time after there.
He thought,
I thought it was just pretty nice.
I didn't really know who gave,
was actually I had no idea who it was and it wasn't,
it seems to work out well for you.
It wasn't a particularly like insane,
like it was a nice home,
but like it didn't,
you know,
suggest anything other than Gabe was a reasonably wealthy guy who was pretty
interesting and unusual and uh,
and low key.
And then I met him again because he's also friends with Neil Stevenson and,
and so I did that,
that event.
And so those were my two meetings with gay prior to the third meeting where
grant Crilly for modern cuisine,
Ryan,
Matthew Smith,
who was the photographer on modernist cuisine and myself plus a college friend
of mine,
Ed starboard,
we'd sort of started up a company called Dell that was a consulting company that
went on to become a,
the company it is today,
which is chef steps.
And like,
we were self funding this and like rapidly running out of the,
not a lot of money we had.
And so we were going to do I a,
uh,
a cookbook and because of modernist cuisine,
a lot of publishers wanted to talk to us and we sort of went,
well,
we'll,
we'll give them the physical book,
but we want to do stuff with the digital stuff.
And we kept hitting this roadblock of like publishers were smart enough to say
we want the digital rights,
but like they had no idea what they wanted to do with it.
They were just smart enough and greedy enough to like,
we should totally ask for them.
So we're like,
well Gabe does a lot of stuff in and like digital video game publisher,
we should ask him like how he approached us.
And so we just asked to meet with him and we went over to valve and we're like,
we're doing this,
we're trying to do this book deal.
And we're like getting hung up on the digital publishing rights and how would
you like suggest we might think about this?
And he goes,
well I don't know anything about the book publishing world,
but I do know a lot about the video game publishing world.
And it's a terrible idea for creators to give their intellectual property away.
Why would you do that?
And we're like,
because we need the money.
He's like,
what if I gave you a quarter of $1 million right now?
And we're like,
and he's like,
no,
I'm serious.
And he pulls out his iPad and he students me an email right there,
says I will give you $250,000 Gabe and the money showed up the next day.
And we're like,
okay,
well I guess we're not doing the book.
Um,
and that was it.
And so it sort of incrementally came from there.
But it wasn't like games like you know,
the only,
and so a month or so later I think we had dinner and,
and this was like how naive we were.
We had dinner at Canlis in Seattle,
the,
because it was like super good at the time.
And Jason Friday was,
was the chef there and we're like,
we should go there.
And Games,
like I thought catalysts sucked and we're like,
no,
it's,
it's really good now.
So we took him to cannolis and we're chatting,
we're chatting about the culinary world and he's just sort of trying to
understand how our world works and asking us questions like how we're thinking
about our business.
And so Gabe goes,
if I give you $100 million,
what would you guys go build that by building it?
Like there's no value for anyone copying you.
Like I'll give you an example.
Like Intel,
like when they go build a new chip Fab,
it's like billions and billions of dollars and there's no value in anybody else
copying it because not only do they have to spend like even more billions to
catch up,
but like that's been way more billions,
uh,
to basically learn everything else and tell knows about this and then they have
to be like 10 x better for anyone wanting to switch.
So it's like,
it's just a waste of everyone's time.
I sort of laughed that off at the time because like I had no serious answer to
it.
And really over the next two and a half,
three years,
that was us answering that question of like,
what's worth spending $100 million on in the kitchen space?
I mean,
the kitchens,
crazy,
valuable,
cooking's crazy valuable.
What can we go do that,
that like,
that makes sense.
And,
uh,
he,
he was patient enough for us to go on that journey before we're finally like,
okay,
we totally know how to answer that question.
Now we're going to go do this kind of stuff.
And he's like,
well,
that makes sense.
I'm on this train.
Seems like he's also,
I mean I've,
I've only sat in on one sure.
Meeting you guys had,
and this is anything confidential but seems very good at asking questions that
force you to hone in on what you are uniquely capable of doing as opposed to
trying to do two,
three,
four,
five different things simultaneously.
One of which is say cashflow motivated.
Yeah,
no,
he's never asked anything like that.
Um,
in fact,
he very strongly advised against premature monetization like that we would just
go do stupid shit.
And he also sort of advised against running around raising a bunch of money
because it's a really low value use of our creative energies.
Um,
but,
but I'll,
I'll,
I'll rephrase your question.
What gives really good at like,
yes,
that's all to know.
What he's really good at is asking a question where you realize that the way you
answered it,
you are an imbecile.
Like,
like I've just gotten used to basically feeling like I am a complete moron and
like I can't believe I just said that.
That makes no sense.
I'm like,
I moderately feel good now where I feel like I came out of a meeting and like,
like,
like gave isn't like mentally rolling his eyes from like the,
the,
the idiocy that I like that came out of my mouth.
And does that come about because he will question or ask questions to try to
clarify assumptions and then by speaking it out loud,
you're like,
that makes no fucking sense at all.
What I just said,
basically that it's his ability to sort of surface what the real issue is and be
like,
you weren't even looking at the real issue.
The real issue is this,
you don't look as good at that.
I mean,
I dunno,
uh,
you've,
you've spent a fair amount of time with Matt Mullenweg.
I think that's also very good at that.
And that's another person where I basically feel like a complete idiot.
Um,
I also think like,
I look to Matt and go,
I don't know how you know that.
Like I think Matt might be one of the best people I know at running a company
and how he,
how he builds people up.
I,
I aspire to be that good someday.
He a,
I remember Matt asked me at one point were a flying around,
we went to a few word camps together cause I use wordpress and uh,
you don't have since become an advisor to automatic.
But that's relatively recent.
And I was really worked up into a tizzy because there were a bunch of sites
sharing PDFs of the four hour workweek.
It's,
this must have been really early in my career as such,
like 2008 or so.
It was
like rapid,
what the hell was it?
Rapid share I guess are a number of these sites.
And a,
I was trying to talk to Matt about it and get his thoughts because of course
he's missions open source,
but he has a for profit company also.
Uh,
so it's a very interesting set of full philosophical decisions and business
decisions.
I was like,
how should I think about this?
And he's like,
ultimately it came down to talking through it and be like,
oh,
you're totally fucking right.
Like the people who are going to download a Shitty pdf version of this work,
my customers in the first place,
they're never going to buy the book.
It's not like they would have bought the book but then found it for free.
And at the same time I'm just getting free marketing dollars and maybe at some
point they'll,
there'll be converted over to wanting to sort of exchange value for the value
that I'm putting out there into the world.
And he was totally right and I was like,
okay,
rendered all of this angst and all of these time consuming potential avenues.
Irrelevant.
I was like,
wow.
Well that's a load off my mind.
Uh,
the,
the meeting with gay reminded me of a expression that you hear a lot here in
silicon valley,
which is a,
if you want money,
ask for advice and if you want advice,
ask for money.
Yeah,
it seems to,
it seems to have worked out a valve.
Hmm.
Uh,
the only thing,
the only familiarity I really have with valve is their employee handbook does a
pdf that's floated around for quite a few years,
which I thought was genius really.
And it sounds so boring,
but if,
if people look it up and I'll put it in the show notes,
only HR document you will ever knowingly want to read.
Yeah.
It's fascinating.
How has that affected or how his,
how do you think about building your company?
So how,
how,
how is it different?
I think we're now getting to the point,
Um,
I think early on there were,
I'll say it this way,
I tend to think that valve as a culture is Gabes personal reaction to everything
he really didn't like about the Microsoft culture.
And Gay was a very early and an important employee at Microsoft.
Um,
so valve was sort of like,
these are all the things that I think are,
why Microsoft is not going to do well in the long term and we're going to get
them right here.
And he built valve that way.
And and uh,
valve employee,
Joe Ludwig.
I remember asking me like how much of chef steps culture that we copy from valve
just because that's what like Gabe told us to.
And I'm like,
well Gabe never told us to copy valves called tree.
Never particularly encouraged that.
He did encourage us to think in certain ways that I think are going to bring you
to those decisions.
But in a sense Microsoft culture came from bill and Nathan and I worked for
Nathan for five years and I worked on projects that reported to Nathan and bill,
um,
for another year after modernist cuisine was done in,
I can tell you in my estimation,
the Microsoft culture came from those guys and I was just as primed when I was
starting chef steps to have a reaction to everything I didn't like about those
cultural sensibilities of running a business.
And so chef steps,
much like valves,
partially a reaction to those are the things that I didn't think,
uh,
worked very well for running a company that's supposed to get the best,
most innovative,
most interesting work out of people.
What are the things that don't work,
at least for you?
For me,
I,
so especially when you're in the invention or innovation phases,
traditional goal oriented management is not incredibly helpful.
You're basically in 19,
this class of people whose job it is to tell these incredibly creative people
what they should and shouldn't be doing and trying to judge them by some
arbitrary metric.
Like that's a waste of everybody's time and anybody who's really good isn't
going to tolerate it for very long and we'll leave.
Um,
now conversely,
you can get really,
really flaky creative people who never get anything done and like you'll tear
your hair out.
Well,
don't hire those people.
We pretty much exclusively learn to hire people that are,
have a demonstrated track record of doing incredibly creative,
innovative things in whatever domain was relevant to their job.
And they had a proven track record of they've shipped stuff.
They've got stuff done and we're like,
well that's like highly predictive.
We think of like you'll be able to do the same here and if we have people like
you,
we don't need to manage you.
Like you know how to use your time better than we do.
So it's your choice how you spend your time,
you're free to make good choices and you're free to make terrible choices and if
you make enough terrible choices,
like your team may ask you to leave because nobody wants to work with you and if
you make lots of good choices,
we're going to trust you to make more good choices.
And so that sort of leads you down the road of of flatness.
Where you run into some challenges is when you're working on a shorter timeframe
because you don't have infinite amounts of money or when you have to sort of
really align everyone pretty tightly towards a common goal that we need to ship.
We need to pull six teams together to make this product ship and to monetize it
and,
and not flub the lodge.
That's where we're,
we're definitely seeing there are struggles with flatness one approach.
One,
the conventional wisdom is we should basically uh,
create a hierarchy to do this.
I'm kind of fighting that right now because I think that's a short term gain and
a longterm disaster.
I totally agree.
There needs to be structure,
we need to have people that get that they can clearly signal that they're being
trusted to lead,
but we don't want to make that permanent.
And I think this is another thing we've learned from,
from,
from valve that I think is fundamentally a pretty good lesson,
which is people tend to want to keep working on the things that made them
successful in the first place.
That's antithetical to invent it.
Innovation invention.
And if you're a small startup company where like your advantage is speed towards
doing something nobody else is doing,
that's not a very good structure for finding those opportunities.
And,
and I tend to believe that for the type of business we are over the coming
years,
we're going to constantly have to reinvent ourselves in the people that are
really important.
Today may not be the most important people to the company in five years when we
might be about something totally different.
The problem is if we anoint those people as special senior managers,
leaders,
those people will tend to want to keep working on the things that got them in
that position.
And that's not in the interest of the company.
It's in the interest of them.
And pretty quickly you have rent seeking behavior and and power politics and
fiefdoms where the only solution for the company is to periodically come and
just do this wholesale house cleaning of firing a bunch of people who used to be
good because they've actually gotten in the way of the company.
So we sort of took the attitude of like,
let's just not create that structure in the first place.
And that's why even though we have the tension now,
we're pushing out a very complex product where we have to hit a lot of things
right?
And there's a real emphasis on disciplined execution,
taking the short term easy way out of let's create a bunch of people who are
managers of this process.
Like,
I'm totally convinced that that will fuck us up in a couple of years.
Are there any books or people who have most influenced how you make business
decisions?
I think there's a law,
quite a few people.
I'm,
I'm always looking for perspective.
I think Matt actually has influenced me a lot.
I think there's people within chef steps,
uh,
Michael Napkin who's,
you know,
sort of as close as we get to something like a CTO.
Um,
he certainly influenced me a lot on how to think about some of the technical
decisions we make.
In terms of other people that come,
come to mind.
Uh,
absolutely Gabe and people like Yan Bernay over at valve have influenced my
thinking a lot.
My father's influenced my thinking a lot.
I read lots of business articles.
There's,
there's some stuff there,
stuff that I think a lot of people in the valley read that certainly I pay
attention to it and I think about it and some of it I think is pretty right on.
And I think other stuff is like super wrong headed.
So I don't know that there's like any one person,
I'm looking to.
The,
the other thing I come back to is I try to look at the data and I really try to,
I'm sort of prone to changing my mind a lot and it's,
it can feel random,
but it's almost always because I'm seeing something in the data that,
that I thought was true,
but the data is saying it's not true.
And so I have new information and I think the only rational thing to do,
and I have new information has changed my mind that can actually feel pretty
randomizing to a team.
So I'm,
I'm trying to find ways to buffer that.
Um,
or to at least help them reach the point where they're changing their minds to
without it just,
you know,
basically Chris has changed his mind.
That's,
that's not a good outcome.
So we tend to buy us towards people who are pretty quantitative in their
decisions,
especially on the business side where we say,
well,
like,
let's listen to our customers.
What does the data really telling us?
What are they really telling us?
And let's make sure we're not fooling ourselves with anecdotes.
Yeah.
You know,
I,
uh,
I've done two books,
very helpful for that as someone who is,
I wouldn't say particularly mathematically inclined or who got derailed by a bad
teacher in 10th grade.
And if I want to point fingers,
uh,
the I support finger pointing
one,
which I want to actually go back and reread or listened to and I believe it's
available for free and audio is high output management by Andy Grove.
Uh,
and uh,
the other,
which I think is helpful for conditioning oneself or others if it's kind of
prescribed as reading for spotting cognitive biases and learning to try to trust
the data is,
um,
it's a fun way to predictably irrational by Dan Arielli.
So to shift gears just a little bit,
I want to talk about goal setting.
Of course that's maybe an underlying layer upon which many other things are
built almost by definition,
but could we start with gliding?
What does,
what does competitive gliding and what are some of your goals there?
So competitive gliding is,
uh,
there's different ways of doing it,
but as I usually practice it,
uh,
we're in gliders.
These are big 15,
20 meters,
15 to 20 meter sail planes,
um,
made from carbon fiber,
fiberglass composites,
and we're usually basically racing the sun.
Uh,
you know,
we get all of our energy for a competition out of,
uh,
the fact that the sun heats,
the atmosphere of that causes differ differential heating and you get thermals,
which you see birds circling in and puffy clouds at the top of you get sheer
where you get wins that basically may be lifted up,
uh,
over mountains that create lift.
We'll get mountain wave where the atmosphere actually starts to oscillate.
And we can surf that for hundreds,
if not thousands of miles
soup,
no propeller.
We get towed up into this end of this guy,
a couple thousand feet by another plane.
And once we come off that tow rope,
it's ours to go find energy.
So it's like big wave surfing,
except you're on air and you can't see it and you'd have to look at the
telltale.
So our job is to basically read where the atmosphere is giving up free energy.
The way a race will work is we'll call usually turn points.
And so we might call,
they might be a city,
they might be an airfield,
they might be a geographic feature and these can be uh,
a hundred miles apart,
more,
maybe a little bit less.
And there's cylinders around them.
Usually it turns cylinders we call them,
where you can sort of imagine these imaginary cylinders in the sky that are
anywhere from five miles to maybe 20 miles around a turn point.
And our job is to basically decide when to turn on those,
um,
and get back to our,
our home airfield.
But the challenge is you're given a minimum time on course.
So we have to be out for say three or four hours.
And if you come back early,
whatever distance you flew gets divided by the minimum time,
which obliterate your average speed.
Um,
and if you come way over,
you might've covered more distance,
but your average speed also goes down.
And so the very best pilots,
we'll usually time it pretty well to get back within a couple minutes of that
time.
Um,
over a four hour race that might cover anywhere from three to 500 kilometers.
And what you're really,
you're enough of the landscape where the sky's going to change on you.
You've got to decide when to start that.
That's one of the other secrets is you get to,
they opened a a start gate but you get to choose when to start.
And so there's a whole strategy and game theory behind when to do that.
And the top pilots are all very good at this as we call it start gate roulette
where like the top pilots,
we'll,
we'll go out and be seen to go out in a bunch of,
the lesser pilots will follow them and then they'll try to duck behind a cloud,
get lost,
come back and restart and then follow all of those people who are essentially
acting as markers out on course of where there's energy and where there's clear
like the canaries in the coalmine or totally the canaries.
Um,
I have been that can area when I was not more experience where I was like,
oh look,
he's going,
I should just follow that.
I just follow that person.
I know I was being suckered.
And what's really interesting about it is it's physically demanding.
Um,
it's actually,
you're getting a lot of sun.
You're pulling,
we might spend upwards of 30% of the time circling,
but those circles are anywhere from 1.2 to 1.35.
Oh I'm sorry,
1.75 g forces.
Maybe occasionally you'll pull two GS.
You can actually pull a lot more to glider,
but that's atypical and erase.
But you might be pulling those g forces of,
of,
you know,
one and a half g's for 30 minutes or more when you're dehydrated,
when you're getting a lot of sense.
So it's very,
and you're changing altitude,
which constricts and expand your capillary systems.
Here,
you're always having to pee or you're always dehydrated depending on whether
you're going up or going down.
So there's this big part of it where you have to manage your physiology for
several hours.
You have to be very disciplined in your decision making because the difference
between first and second or third might only be one,
one and a half minutes.
That's usually only three extra circles during a four hour race where you might
actually do hundreds and hundreds and hundreds of circles.
So it's all about efficiency.
It's do I bay?
It's,
it's do I need to make this turn or should I be going and what do,
what do I think the atmosphere is going to be doing in 10 minutes?
And where do I think it's going to be good?
And where do we think it's bad?
So it's,
it's extremely strategic.
It's also extremely tactical because you're still having to fly the airplane.
And so you're flipping constantly back and forth between the fly the airplane,
because I might be in a climb with 10 other airplanes,
a fraction of a wingspan.
We're all circling together within inches.
And so it's a highly coordinated formation flying where it's like the rule is
don't crash into the other guy.
Um,
but we're also having to do all the mental calculations of wins at time to go,
where am I going next?
And you're always trying to think well ahead of the airplane.
And so I find that it's incredibly focusing and you're like,
you have no choice but to be totally in the moment.
Um,
and to be extremely focused on what you're feeling,
the way the airplane's feeling,
what other,
what,
what the right strategy is.
And I just find that incredibly addicted in the fact that you can take this
technology and just by reading the telltales of the sky around us,
find enough free energy to go fly at a average speeds that,
uh,
approach a hundred miles an hour and cover hundreds of miles of distance over
beautiful mountains or desert floors where if you land,
it's like you're going to be walking a very long time to the nearest road.
I,
it's just,
it's amazing.
This is going to seem unrelated,
but do you,
how well do you typically sleep?
Do you have trouble getting to sleep most of the time?
Yes.
Okay.
The reason I ask is that I am doing a lot better now for a host of reasons for
another,
then I can save for another time.
But I've always had onset insomnia.
And so I've been attracted to activities like that where you cannot let,
there's a huge penalty.
You can do it if you let your mind wander or obsess on other things.
There's an enormous penalty.
And so I just find it to be a huge sort of stress release valve.
It's almost like meditating to engage in an activity like that.
For me,
it's,
that's a big part of it.
It's one of the few things that if I go off to a glider competition for a couple
of weeks,
or if or I go to go flying in,
in southern New Zealand,
which I do every couple of years,
I was there,
I was there in November and it's,
it's as amazing as you would think.
Um,
it's all consuming.
My entire schedule starts revolving around flying.
And because competitions are usually held over multiple days too.
So it's about consistency.
You know,
if you're in first the only place to go as backwards.
Um,
and so it's all about low risk.
Whereas if you're in fifth,
it's,
you've got to be better the next day and take risks,
but you might blow up a new horrible,
it's,
it's the counterpoint to the rest of my life where it's very unstructured,
can be very chaotic and that's just part of how it works.
Whereas this is sort of extremely structured,
extremely focusing in highly rewarding.
So what is your current,
what are your current goals are biggest goal in gliding?
Uh,
so the biggest goal is setting a distance,
record a world distance records.
So these days,
the world record I think is over 3000 kilometers.
So about a 3009,
I think.
And it was set in the Andes.
Um,
and really that's the only place left to set a record that big because what
happens is the prevailing winds flow from west to east and they,
there is a pig long mountain chain that runs up South America called the Andes.
Those winds slam into and as they rise over it,
um,
they rise to a level where they become unstable.
So they start to fall and it overdoes it in each direction.
And so it starts to oscillate and the whole atmosphere starts are,
and where you can climb into what we call a mountain wave and you can climb up,
I think the records over 50,000 feet and there's people attempting for a hundred
thousand feet.
But once you get in that wave,
you can surf it,
you can run it parallel to the mountains,
you may have to jump where the mount,
where the mountain range zigs and Zags.
You've got to read what's going on.
It's,
it's not as simple as just put the nose down,
but you're flying at the red line of the airplane.
Like you fly even a nod or two faster and the whole wings get,
you know,
we'll basically explode,
which is bad.
Well,
you're doing that at this point.
They're now doing that up the length of the Andes and back down where they're
racing against daylight because the records have to be set 30 minutes before
legal sunrise to 30 minutes after legal sunset.
That's the time you have allotted.
And if you're flying at the very limits of the airplane,
you're limited by the speed of the airplane.
So I commissioned an airplane called the Duck Hawkin DNX built by this
incredible genius.
Greg Kohl in bend,
Oregon.
And Greg was applying new technologies,
new manufacturing techniques to build an airplane that's about 40% faster than
any other slider.
That's a significant jump in as possible because he wasn't true.
He was trying to optimize for a very specific problem and who is willing to use
new technologies and try things that most people thought were a bit crazy and
either I'm crazy or,
or,
or not.
And if it's the not case,
then Greg's built an incredible airplane,
the at,
um,
uh,
that is capable of doing what no other airplane is capable of doing.
And so this is going to take several seasons of training.
Um,
this kind of flying is highly technical.
You've,
you really have to manage your physiology.
You can go hypoxic cause you're usually operating at 20 to 30,000 feet.
So you're on oxygen.
Um,
your solo in an airplane,
it's minus 80 degrees Celsius outside and you're dealing with wins.
That could be a hundred plus Maya nots.
And how much spaces around you,
uh,
in the airplane?
Yeah,
I wear it is the best way to describe it.
It's very snug.
You feel the flex of the wings,
you feel uh,
what the atmosphere is doing and you want to do that.
And uh,
so the,
the,
the plan is in a few years to,
is to start spending seasons down there.
I'm trying to do these big record flights and there's both the air frame and
then there's the possibility of sensorized in the airplane so that the airplane
in certain respects can respond faster than a human can by automating the flaps,
um,
based on what various,
uh,
accelerometers and memes gyros are doing.
So this is where people at chef steps are like totally freaked out because I've
been writing my own firmware for controlling my automated flaps now.
All right,
so we were talking about like confidence versus Hubris.
What,
what is compelling you to do that?
Are there not other,
because from what I've gathered,
you're not a software engineer,
no coders.
So do you have like such and such for dummies and you were just putting together
the firmware or why would you do it yourself versus two?
Twofold.
So one,
I'm lucky to be surrounded by a bunch of people who are in fact very good
engineers and I absolutely ask them for advice and in fact I even asked them for
code reviews now because like this is a little bit bonkers.
The other part of it though is twofold.
One,
I like to know how things work.
I like to know how they're built and while I expect I will need the help and
assistance of other people to fully implement what I want to do,
I want to be part of doing that.
I want to know why various choices were made or what the trade offs are.
Partially,
it gives me confidence.
Like I'm used to working on my airplane.
I'm used to understanding everything about how it's built.
I'm relying on the software to do a lot of things to augment my abilities.
I want to know how it's built.
I want to know when it's going to do bat,
might do bad things and when it basically can't do bad things.
It's a good answer.
You're talking about the structure and required level of detail in gliding
versus a lot of the rest of your life at least let's just say in a professional
sense which is unstructured.
So add a note to talk to you about the value of a less structured day and I was
hoping you could just elaborate on that because
you seem to have both in your life.
I you need both.
I think I'm more at least I suppose I need both to do some of the things I want
to accomplish.
In other words,
absolutely no structure.
There are certain types of things I'd never be able to accomplish.
Gliding is one of them,
but actually running a company requires a certain amount of structure.
On the other hand,
I spend a lot of my time venting and I don't think inventing is something that
is very amenable to mean structured.
I think inventing 10 it's a bit like writing where some days you're prolific,
some days nothing's coming,
sometimes weeks nothing is coming in and you start to get super nervous about
deadlines that have come and gone and like you're avoiding your email and your
cell phone because people are angry at you.
But to those types of activities they take the time they take and I have
basically found that I need to build part of my life
highly unstructured.
If I wake up,
when I wake up,
I stay up til three in the morning reading something,
working on something that's all sort of grist for the mill that's just
percolating there and in ways I can't predict,
but I've come to learn will come at a certain rate that has,
I've found in my career allowed me to make certain leaps,
figure certain things out or come up with something where if I tried to force it
or structure it,
I would have taken a very predictable path because it was like,
oh well we just need to solve this,
this problem and this is how you do it.
Versus you have this flashes of brilliance where like,
oh,
this is what we need to do and that I just don't believe that kind of creativity
is very amenable destruction.
So I try to have part of my life,
even though it can be kind of insane for everyone else where like if I want to
stay up all night,
if I going to get up late,
if I have a meeting,
it's going to get canceled.
It's just like I'm not structuring my time.
It's my time to do whatever I want with it.
Whatever rate feels right that day.
And I've started to find,
I need to basically carve out very big chunks.
The minimum chunk seems to be about half a day where like don't expect me to be
doing anything else because I'm not going to guarantee you it'll happen.
I'm just busy letting myself enjoy life.
So what does that look like?
Or what do you hope it will look like on say a basis?
So one of the,
the really epiphany's but realizations I had a few years ago is that many of my
friends who are highly effective human beings thought of batching certain
activities on specific days of the week.
In other words,
it wasn't that they would check email,
have meetings,
set goals,
brainstorm and journal and 15 other activities each day.
They would batch certain types of tasks or unstructured time.
Right?
And so for me,
that means generally speaking,
batch recording audio on Mondays and Fridays,
uh,
unstructured time for just creation.
Whenever that happens to mean in a given week on Wednesdays from like 9:00 AM to
1:00 PM.
So,
even if I am,
my goal is to have sort of room to think and space.
If I don't create that space in my calendar,
it's very likely that it'll get overrun with other stuff.
Uh,
how do you,
how do you think about that?
Or are there certain rules?
Like if then,
like you just said,
like if I stay up late,
then I will clear the decks and like send an email before I go to bed saying,
hey,
like wipe the decks up until this point in time.
So there's some of that.
Um,
I haven't found that totally effective for myself,
although I have to do so.
I love it because I have a responsibility of running a company and they have,
uh,
you know,
I need to be available to certain people or it's just not being fair or it's
impeding their effectiveness and their productivity.
And I have definitely surrounded myself with types of people that are very
complimentary to me of people who are more focused on organization and being
productive and a very specific kind of way.
I tend to find that,
especially when I'm getting into something where I'm trying to solve a very
specific problem,
but it's open ended.
In fact,
I'm not even totally sure I can define what the problem is.
Like I might need to carve out weeks where like the majority of my time is going
to be going into this activity that may or may not be productive and may or may
not be a terribly good use of my time.
It's just this rabbit hole that I kind of need to dig in.
And so that tends to be one where increasingly I'm trying to find chunks of my
life where I can literally carve out,
like I'm going to commit 20% of my time to basically attending to some of the
details of,
you know,
being married and have a family running a company.
But I'm also going to allocate a huge amount of my,
my free time or I'm going to create a huge amount of free time to spend hours in
days.
And even in some cases more than a week just chugging away on this to see where
it gets.
Um,
and sometimes,
uh,
you know,
I come up at a zero,
like that was a waste of time,
but I've found over the last decade or so that those periods of time have turned
out to be incredibly important for finding something that's insanely valuable.
Well,
I,
you know,
this is maybe it's just rationalizing so that I don't go totally insane,
but I've,
I remember a
coming to a similar conclusion related to writing because I became very
frustrated once at a draft of a chapter where it was something like 10 pages in
nine and a half pages were just garbage.
I mean,
complete garbage.
But there was a colonel,
unlike the ninth page of a few paragraphs that ended up becoming the beginning
of a really strong chapter.
And I was like,
wow,
that was a really big fucking waste of time.
I can't believe that.
I only got a few paragraphs out of that.
And the,
uh,
one of my friends who I guess you could view as a mentor of sorts of very
seasoned,
successful writers said,
no,
no.
You're missing the point.
Like you needed those first nine and a half shitty pages to get to the good
stuff.
You couldn't have started there.
And I was like,
oh,
okay,
that's at least a healthy way to look at it.
I basically totally agree with that.
If there's no shortcuts,
like I can look back on the evolution chef steps has gone through since 2012 or
the evolution I've gone through since,
uh,
99 2000 and I can see all of these periods where it was like,
oh,
that wasn't super productive or I didn't accomplish what I had hoped to
accomplish with that.
It's easy in hindsight to say,
well,
maybe you could have cut that out or maybe you could have shortened this
timescale in the market or something like that.
And it's like,
I don't,
I don't think so.
I don't think we would have had the thoughts or reach as a comment a certain
rate.
And all of those things in some way tend to lead into the,
into that solution.
There's so much,
uh,
of the,
so many people I read that it's focused on efficacy and being effective in
managing your time.
And doing these things as if there's anybody,
anybody like that sitting in this room that is about how to basically get there
faster.
And there are absolutely things in life that are amenable to going faster.
But the really interesting stuff,
the stuff where like nobody else is doing it,
it really is a breakthrough or it is an invention or is an innovation or it's
just a new piece of art or whatever it is.
It takes the time it takes and you can't force it.
Well,
there's also,
I mean another way to,
sorry to interrupt with like another way to look at it is like to optimize the
process.
There has to be a process and if you're trying to connect dots that have never
been connected before or create the dots,
there is no algorithm to tweak yet.
I mean,
but other people might argue differently and I think there are some tools that I
found helpful like the Edward de Bono six thinking hats type of stuff.
But generally you're just sitting there fucking staring at your navel a lot.
Yeah.
And waiting for an apple then totally useless.
Um,
I'm working really hard.
Trust me.
I actually okay with that.
I people and like thankfully you haven't asked us because I,
I have no good answer of like,
what's your creative process?
I have no idea.
Like I like I could make something up.
I don't actually spend a lot of time thinking about my creative process.
I mostly focused on the what are the interesting ideas that I'm having right now
that seem worth pursuing and for whatever reason one may win out over another,
it pulls on me more strongly and I just follow that and that has like served me
super well.
It's like you keep meeting these people,
you keep you eating these things and it's,
I've just pulled on threads and follow where they go.
I want to hit you with some rapid fire questions.
Number one,
what is your creative process?
No,
please describe for the next 10 minutes your creative process.
What do you think of the word successful?
Who's the first person who comes to mind and why?
My father and because I think he's actually had a pretty happy life.
He has a family around him.
He's achieved some business success and he's done a lot of things that he's
created a lot of meaning for people.
And so I admire that the fact that he has created a lot of meaning for people in
his house.
So what type of meaning?
Um,
I suppose I would answer it by,
it depends on who we're talking about.
I think in,
in,
in the world of,
of his employees,
a lot of the employees have been there for as long as the business of around and
they find value in it.
They find a and a meaningful thing to do with,
with their lives.
And the fact that there's been that loyalty to them and they've,
and they've,
they've clearly felt that it was a valuable use of their time,
uh,
that was meaningful for his family.
It's the fact that,
um,
we're still a family and that he's created meaning for me and meaning for my
brother and my mother.
And more broadly speaking,
our extended family,
we had,
we had lots of exchange students growing up,
especially through high school.
And they still come back and visit and they're coming back with their families
now and they really attach a lot of importance and meaning to their time with my
family.
And,
uh,
and that was really created for my father and my mother as well.
Um,
so how did they create that bond?
Or what were the,
what were the ways?
Because that's in my jeans.
That's unusual,
right?
It's,
it's atypical.
I mean,
I guess I never thought it was that atypical,
but um,
because I think they were very inclusive and supportive of,
of these people and,
and made sure they had a memorable year and that they,
um,
got to do fun things,
fun things as a family felt included in our family.
And even after they'd left,
you know,
we'd stay in touch,
we'd go on trip to Europe and we'd see them.
And so,
you know,
I think that,
even 20 years later now,
we're still having reunions and,
and I think that's created a lot of meaning for people in their life other than
your dad.
If you had to pick a second person,
dead or alive,
doesn't matter.
Fictional or nonfictional?
Winston Churchill.
Okay.
W why Winston?
So I think this,
I,
there's,
there's a great series of,
of,
of books,
the last lion by William Manchester on Winston Churchill and the f the third
volume actually just came out a few years ago posthumously,
but the first two,
which really only got up to his life at the outbreak of world war two,
like it didn't even touch on the,
everything that happened afterward to started.
Like I just remember being like,
he was a bestselling author by 20,
he'd fought in wars,
he was,
you know,
uh,
one of the highest paid writers.
He an important member of parliament,
all of these things.
And it's like he's a fascinating individual.
And I remember reading these and I was probably in my early twenties being this
like,
man,
I suck compared to this.
I am way behind.
So I think on some level it was like,
that's what historic level of success looks like.
And,
and like as a history professor pointed out to me,
you weren't born into the British aristocracy of say you're working with a
deficit to begin with,
which like fair enough.
But I think I've always looked at it,
things like that as as being like of lasting significance and,
and I suppose that drives me on some level.
That description makes me want to see a celebrity death match.
Claymation of Winston Churchill versus Ben Franklin.
Oh,
Churchill is totally taken frank down and he was a,
he was a crippled and Churchill has them en masse by at least five x.
He's like,
he's drunk.
He was a big unit.
Yeah.
And he could hold his liquor.
Do you have any superstitions?
And the reason I ask is that I find it in a way a stress reduction for me to
prize a handful of superstitions because I tried to be so hyper analytical and
other areas like I don't like using red pens for instance,
which I think I picked up an Asia somewhere.
They don't like using red ink for a handful of things.
Cheersing with water don't like it.
I don't know if this qualifies as a superstition,
but as much as I said like I'm about lack of structure and stuff,
I certainly found as a writer that it was incredibly important for me to have
certain things.
Just so with writing,
I would have a very specific ritual about driving to a very specific coffee shop
and I had to have sort of one or two very specific tables.
If,
if they were like filled,
like I'd sit there with my coffee just sort of like leering at them.
I'm like,
you are taking my table,
don't you know,
like that I'm trying to finish a manuscript.
Excuse me.
So dude,
do you know who I am?
It was like,
I come here so much,
this should be my table.
Um,
so that's one of these things where like I actually really,
really struggled to write if I broke that pattern.
So,
I don't know if it qualifies as a superstition,
but I certainly found like having the,
the,
you know,
it's almost sort of like you need to like walk in a circle three times and you
know,
have this particular mug or none of the magic will work.
It's totally one of those.
And so if like something would go missing,
like it was total freak out.
Like I have to have that or I'm doomed.
So.
So you drive to the coffee shop?
Yeah.
What were the characteristics of the table that made it the right table?
It was in a window.
It was a two person table.
It's sat in such a way that people weren't terribly intrusive when they were
coming or going like you weren't constantly getting bumped,
but there was a bit of activity behind it that sort of provided just this white
noise that allowed me to focus.
So it was,
you know,
it wasn't that table per se,
it was that table in that particular coffee shop like worked where it was just
the right balance between feelings among people,
but without the distraction of people.
Do you listen to music when you write?
I will and usually some pretty,
a lot of techno,
a lot of late nineties techno.
I'm logically,
I might listen to like Paul Oakenfold live at the Ro Jan in Shanghai.
It's an essential mix and it's like,
to this day when I'm doing certain kinds of work,
it's put the headphones on and you know,
at soundcloud and it's old essential mixes with Pete Tong.
How many pages of text that you were involved with in some capacity?
We're in modernist cuisine roughly of the pages I wrote.
I think I wrote around 300,000 words.
So how many,
uh,
what does that break down too?
I mean,
that's like
pictures and full bloods outside to six
full length book was,
it was a million over a slightly over a million words,
uh,
for the,
for the final book.
And uh,
you know,
it was 20,
I think it was 2,400 pages.
It's long enough now I'm starting to forget,
but it 50 pounds of book
when you did first drafts,
was that on a computer by hand on a computer?
On a computer?
What program was it?
Just standard word.
They was worried at the time.
Yeah.
Um,
I experiment of some other things.
I actually write,
I write a lot with a program called AIAA writer because it sort of blank.
It's everything out and a writer and I enjoy that.
I think there's like cooler,
better stuff that I haven't even heard of yet,
but another one called Hemingway than a lot of folks have mentioned.
It's like I find something that works and just leave it alone.
Yeah.
There's one called scrivener that I've used for my last few books that I really
enjoy.
It's the reason I like it is that you can lay out all of your chapters within a
single window on the left hand side,
like a,
like a vertical scroll and you can move them around dragging and dropping into
say sections and then you can have a split pane on the right side showing the
texts that you're working on and then have your research notes below it,
which I just found so incredibly helpful for the last two books.
How do you edit when you,
when you have say your first brain dump of stuff,
how would you,
what is your editing process?
There's like what does my good editing process and then like what is the battle
I must fight?
My tendency is to actually edit myself as I write and do a lot of polishing that
really would be better served after I got the words out.
My preferred approach and what tends to be best for me is I do my writing in the
uh,
the evenings and I do my editing in the morning.
I like it.
I will usually wake up after having like written until three in the morning and
then I'll wake up at like nine,
nine 30 or 10 or whatever.
And I go back and like,
oh my God,
this was incredibly indulgent.
But you know,
there's 9,000 words,
so I'm going to be able to find some good nuggets here and I can start iterating
on it pretty quickly that,
that works well.
Would you kick out 9,000 words a session?
Uh,
I'm the sometimes,
yes.
Holy Shit.
That was usually all that would usually get paired down,
which three you tick is a lot.
I don't even remember that could end up in that.
That might end up,
it's something like 1500 words when it's done,
it's a,
it'll be a lot of slop.
Sometimes it'll be whole sections where it's just like I'll leave it there and,
and just,
uh,
picked up again.
So it's a total mess at that point.
But there's ideas to work with.
I got the ideas down more typical session would probably be 750 to 2000 words
depending on the closer it was to seven 50 the user,
the usually the less work I had to do on editing,
but often it would take three times as long as if I just barfed out 300 or less
grist for the mill to work with in the first place.
What is your favorite documentary or movie or any favorites that come to mind?
So like right now I think I'm going through like a,
an eighties nostalgia Benj.
Uh,
I've been watching some John Hughes movies lately that I've enjoyed.
I,
I can't really do like a c what does the saving was Doubtfire or no,
no,
it's,
it's like Ferris Bueller's Day off and,
and uh,
stuff like that.
Um,
uh,
and old John Cusack movies that I've really,
really loved.
Pulp Fiction was like super.
So I was living in Germany at the time as an exchange student.
I was homesick and pulp fiction came out and I remember seeing it in German
because everything was dubbed there.
And Samuel L.
Jackson sounds horrible as a German,
I'm not a funny,
not Samuel L.
Jackson.
So I was lucky enough that I lived in oak right by the hall,
uh,
the,
the border between Holland,
Belgium and Germany.
So I remember driving to a town called hair Lynn and seen it in English and it
was like so great to basically just see some this movie in English after I had
been like hearing nothing but German and was super homesick.
So I like that movie still stands out as a movie.
I love documentaries.
Any documentaries?
Oh,
so this one sort of between,
I'd call this docu drama.
It's partly documentary and it's partly a not entirely true the right stuff.
I'm a pilot.
I love flying in that movie was just like,
I got to do this.
Like where do I sign up to get one of these rides?
So I need to see.
That's a great movie.
I haven't seen that film in ages.
What purchase of $100 or less has most positively impacted your life in recent
memory?
So I'll,
I'll,
I'll give two answers.
I bought a new electric tea kettle.
I used to do,
I used to have all the stove top kettles.
Like even though I knew that it was vastly better,
I underestimated how much better my life would be by having an electric tea
kettle so that I can have like tea actually quickly and more or less on demand
with very little fuss.
So like I think I paid,
I think I have an oxo clear a one button,
nothing fancy tea kettle and it's flipping awesome.
So much so that I've liked now bought them at work too so I can just have them
everywhere.
So that was great.
And I don't remember exactly what the price is,
but I'm going to go with it.
Anyway.
I bought,
bought the we a DJ hero for my nine year old son and me and it's awesome because
one,
he loves it and loves doing it,
but,
but to I totally won't let him win.
I used a brief Dj,
um,
back with some techniques and,
and,
and a college,
it was like my way of going to a fraternity party without having to go to the
fraternity party.
Like I get paid to go DJ and do them.
And so like when we get to like the scratching competitions and stuff with Jack,
like I totally can't let him win,
but we have so much fun with that.
So I think that might've been just over the threshold.
But in terms of like make my life awesome and time to spend with my son,
it's great.
If you were to teach a ninth or 10th grade class,
what would you focus on?
What would you teach?
Tough call.
It's a tossup between Shakespeare or I'd be really interested in doing a history
of science class history of science.
Why Shakespeare?
I had a phenomenal,
a teacher in high school that taught me to write John Fitzpatrick.
I think he passed away about a year ago,
which is a bummer because I haven't seen him in probably two decades,
but he taught a whole year of Shakespeare and I,
and I signed up for it because as a senior,
because I'd had him as a sophomore English teacher and right when like every
other teacher hated me or like just,
I was a pain in their butt.
Like he sort of mentored me and put up with a lot of my shenanigans or my
laziness of turning stuff in.
And he really pushed me to,
to,
to right.
I mean,
as a sophomore I think I was right having to write five,
eight page like real papers where and where you're really exploring literature.
So I signed up for him when he taught a year of Shakespeare in my senior year.
And I particularly remember the comedies of just the discussions we had around
it and the ideas and how actually funny they were and how humorous they were
and,
and how great some of the themes were.
Totally blew my mind because like up until then,
Shakespeare's like this really,
um,
uh,
poncy English literature kind of thing to go do.
And actually it was hysterical and they were a blast to read them.
So I would,
I'd want other people to experience that.
I don't know if I could do it justice in the history of science would be option
number two.
Yeah,
I think,
uh,
you know,
I,
I suppose I do.
I don't know that I do science.
I do engineering now.
I think a lot about science,
but I love the ideas.
I love the inevitable inevitable ness of the ideas.
I like the how one idea belt on another.
And when you really have a great history of science teacher who sort of tells
the story of how these things shaped culture shaped the world.
It makes science something more than just the formulas are the equations or
theorems or the idea is that you learn in a fairly dry science textbook,
no matter how much they've made an artsy with sidebars in,
in,
in graphics,
it's,
there were fact that there were people involved in,
it wasn't at all.
Like at the time they might've been hugely controversial ideas and it wasn't so
obvious at the time that like,
you know,
the calculus was right or that,
air was a thing or that germs were a thing and how much controversy and how much
human nests that were around these ideas.
I love that because I think I sort of see it on a day to day basis when you're
inventing stuff,
it feels totally nuts at the time and you're like,
is anybody going to like think this was was worthwhile?
Well,
it also makes me think of a dinner I just had last week,
which was an incredible,
rare opportunity.
But I had a chance to go to a small group dinner with Jim Watson and Watson and
crick and I mean,
he's gotta be,
I don't know exactly,
late eighties,
maybe,
uh,
maybe nine,
maybe nineties,
and completely lucid.
And I was two chairs away,
you know,
so that was one person's separated from him.
Uh,
so co-discoverer of the Double Helix and,
uh,
you know,
turns out I didn't realize this,
but he has probably a half a dozen other discoveries that would have been anyone
else's life work.
And he has a collection of them.
And I,
but I remember having a,
I had a number of short conversations with him and also overheard a lot of,
is fascinating conversations with other folks.
I remember thinking,
you know,
if this were 25 years ago,
I could totally see this one encounter veering me off into becoming a scientist
of some type.
I mean just that one encounter could totally see it by sort of meeting someone
who embodies all the things that felt irrelevant when they're being thrown up by
someone who is far lesser,
far lesser and just not passionate or particularly interested in conveying it to
me in an in a compelling way.
What are your morning rituals?
What does the first students,
60 minutes of your day?
Uh,
first 60 minutes of the day.
So I'm not human if I don't have a shower that's like super,
super important to me.
What time do you usually wake up?
I know it sounds like it moves that moves a lot.
So I given my own devices,
I probably naturally we'll wake up between nine and 10 most days.
I would naturally usually work till three or four in the morning.
Um,
I'm,
I actually experimented with like Bi phasic sleep in college and I would totally
do that still if it didn't make me so unbelievably antisocial.
So what kind of biophysics?
Sleeping?
Uh,
I would basically sleep from 4:00 PM til 8:00 PM and I would work from 8:00 PM
till two or three in the morning.
And then I would sleep from two or three in the morning until usually around
eight or 9:00 AM.
Yeah.
It sounds like the Argentines schedule.
I was wondering how they survived.
I was in Argentina and they would stay out four in the morning,
then go
to work in the morning and,
and I tried to match that.
Now it's just like,
how are these fuckers is surviving?
I don't get it.
And then it's like,
oh no,
no,
no.
Those were,
everybody disappeared.
Yeah,
they have like a two hour lunch,
then they go home at four 30 and sleep until eight o'clock.
So I should move to Argentina to go fly gliders is what I think the conclusion
is I have here.
Um,
it's socially acceptable there.
So you take a shower,
the shower,
I,
I will usually eat something if I'm not feeling totally rushed for time.
It's bacon and eggs.
I'm particularly right now,
there's a recipe on chest ups called the Emoji egg,
which is basically an egg cracked into a nonstick pan.
He did very slowly until it looks like the perfect Emoji of a sunny side up egg
like that.
Maybe a piece of toast and Bacon is great,
but there's a 50,
50 chance that I'm just going out the door at that point.
And the very next stop is a espresso.
We have very nice espresso machines,
courtesy of La Marzocco at chef steps and uh,
we keep the entire company caffeinated.
We keep a world Barista on the team.
Everybody like our,
our,
our job training is if this whole thing doesn't work out with the company,
everybody at chef steps is capable of being a Barista.
Um,
so I get through with the right town for it.
Totally.
I have a lot of stiff competition.
We've got to raise the bar.
But uh,
uh,
so I start the day like many people at that point I will have a latte at work,
usually a more traditional size of five or a six ounce latte.
I don't like a ton of milk,
but it's like,
that's kind of the ritual of okay,
now I can start dealing with whatever I need to do.
If you did not have machines to help you make espresso,
how would you make a good cup of coffee?
I'd bet you make a tea.
Yeah.
So you wouldn't use a chemist or press any of the,
I have all that and I don't mind it but it's,
if somebody else wants it,
I'll do it.
It's a bit fussy but I gotta be kind of like during my time at the fat duck we
had builders,
tea,
um,
tp tips,
just like you came in a giant garbage bag basically stuffed with like really
crappy like tea dust and that with a bunch of milk is just like milky tea.
It's really satisfying in some sort of cringe worthy way.
And,
and I have nicer t than that at home,
but it's still something about the ritual of make some tea.
I steep it,
I like a little bit of milk and,
and if I'm writing or something I can drink gallons of that and not feel guilty.
Like I only need to go to the bathroom a lot,
but it's really satisfying and it just like that's my break every 50 minutes or
so I needed to make another big of that builder's tea builder's tea.
It's,
it's a British a saying of like,
so like the builders on a job site at some point they all get around and make a
cup of tea and this was like the cheap ass,
like cheapest bulk tea you could buy.
And because like the fat duck was a three Michelin Star Restaurant,
which meant we made no money.
Right.
That was what we had.
That's,
that's something that as a the customers we had much nicer.
that's something that surprised me when I was in the midst of working on the
four hour chef,
which of course you were involved with.
And realizing that in effect,
the higher the quality of the food and drink,
well the food especially served at a restaurant,
the lower the margins appear to be.
It's like the more expensive,
the better the food,
the harder it is to run as a business in effect.
I guess I didn't tell the story of,
of nearly going bankrupt at the fat duck.
I mean I,
I was,
uh,
I was there so I,
you know,
it's not really,
my story has Heston story but,
but I'll tell it because it gives some context to this.
So we were a two star restaurant in a,
in most to star restaurants are really just a three star restaurant that's going
out of business.
This was January of 2004.
We were at Madrid fusion,
which at the time was like the biggest chef conference in the world and we were
unknown and like frosted ray was the biggest chef in the world at the time.
Jay Jockey,
James Petri,
who is our pastry chef and I were basically prepping backstage all week for our
demo and all these chefs from all these restaurants in Madrid and around Spain.
We're coming around watching what we were doing because like we were basically
doing crazy stuff.
We had liquid nitrogen,
nobody had seen that we were doing stuff with pressure cookers and vacuum pumps
and all sorts of crazy stuff.
And like in the background of all this,
like Heston couldn't make payroll on Friday and so there's like a ton of stress
on his,
uh,
from him about that and like,
you know,
we are at this really lavish event and we are super well taken care of.
Meanwhile,
back in,
in in Bray like couldn't pay the bills because there were no customers are not
enough customers.
And I remember we were out for lunch with Nick Lander from the Financial Times
he was there,
food cracky taken us out to lunch and we were coming back to the conference and
we were slotted like last slot in the day.
Everybody's usually gone by then,
but because of all the craziness people had been seen us do all week,
there was a buzz going around.
I'm like,
you've got to stay for this,
you've got to stay for this.
So Heston Gay,
um,
got the order out a little bit.
We basically give that presentation at like the 6:30 PM slot,
get a standing ovation from like the 800 chefs and attention for Andrea jumps up
on stage,
throws his arm around.
Hasnin says like,
this is the most important chef cooking today.
And we're like,
like,
what just happened?
This is amazing.
Well next day we go to lunch and it's,
you know,
we're chatting with nick and all this and we come back and like,
we think the restaurant is going to be done.
Well Heston gets a call from machine,
his assistant and she's like,
you know,
I just got a very strange call from the telegraph saying,
what does it feel like to be the third chef in the UK to get their third
Michelin Star?
And had it has things like,
well the guide is not out yet.
Not out yet,
so somebody must be pulling your leg.
And she's like,
well,
I thought that.
So I hung up and I'd call the paper back and they confirmed a journalist was
working on this story.
So we're all kind of sitting in the car looking at trying to like,
well this can't be true.
And Nick just goes,
you know,
if it's true,
let me be the first to congratulate you.
And then right after Heston hangs up Rasheen Derek Balmer,
who is the head of the Michelin Guide Calls Heston cell phone is like,
you know,
I understand you're in Madrid,
we usually like to come in and tell you in person,
but congratulations,
you've earned your third star.
And so we're all gobsmacked and what nobody knew that night is we had zero
customers.
The next day the phone was ringing off the hook and three months later we were
voted best restaurant in the world.
And that was actually um,
really how close it came to basic total implosion.
It was also I think a real lesson for me of one,
you don't do this for the money like this.
The fame and the celebrity and the TV shows and the books and all that in,
in future restaurants did eventually grown into a sizable empire for Huston.
But that wasn't what motivated him.
And I think that was really a big impression on me as well.
It's like,
this isn't why you choose to do things and it is going to get to be a knife edge
like at this,
at some point you have to have faith that it,
it's going to work through under the other side.
I have no idea where that,
no,
it's a great story.
It also makes you wonder how many people who would have been the best in the
world are recognized.
Just missed it by that razor's edge,
you know,
like they one day,
right?
Like the demo came a week after they already missed payroll and that was it.
Like they couldn't do it.
Uh,
which is why I think one of the dangers and a place like silicon valley is you
see these exceptional successes lionized on magazine covers.
But it's a lot like the survivorship bias you might see in like a Barron's or
something where it's like you have all these amazing mutual funds that are
advertising how well I've done for the last five or six years.
And it's like,
well,
those are like the five out of a thousand who managed the gear are gone by skill
or luck.
And you don't know,
uh,
and uh,
it's easy to get sucked in to that sort of fallacy when you don't see the
bodies.
But I guess on that note,
just in terms of these lessons learned and looking at advice that you would give
others then in turn,
what advice would you give your,
uh,
let's say 25 year old self?
If you could place us where you were,
what you were doing or you could choose when you were graduating from a,
from college.
Graduating college is a very diffuse thing for me.
I think it was actually in 2003 I actually applied for my degrees because I
needed them to get my British work permit.
It was one of those,
I'll leave the backdoor open because I'm technically just on sabbatical.
I could always come back.
Um,
even though I stopped going by,
uh,
2001,
I think the,
so,
so I don't know that like when you graduate,
graduate colleges is all that,
all that relevant to me.
I think the more interesting question is what would I basically tell myself in
my later twenties?
I think the advice I would try to give myself is to dispense with a lot more of
the ego and Hubris.
I'd ended up in a,
in a very influential position at a very famous place that felt like you were on
top of the world.
And that does go to your head to have that success,
that quickly,
that early,
um,
to be recognized for it and then to have a string of other great things happen.
You know,
you're surrounded by people that are telling you you're doing great stuff,
how,
how valuable this is,
how important you are.
And most of those people won't be around when that,
that,
that period is over.
But it becomes very seductive and you sort of keep aspiring to take that next
step up.
The Ziggurat,
it's totally irrelevant.
It's a total waste of time,
but it will make you a giant asshole.
I think that was something that it really took over the course of modernist and
subsequent to monitors and the actually even founding chef steps for me to
really grapple with and find comfort in the fact that I'm not really that
interested in celebrity or uh,
those kinds of accolades.
They're nice to get there.
No longer motivating for me at all.
And chasing those actually really made me a jerk because it'd be,
it got me very focused on who is getting credit for what,
how did you,
how'd you make that leap?
I mean,
a lot of people would prefer to be in that were of that mindset,
right?
And not be seduced by the celebrity,
et Cetera.
I mean,
what was the cause it had to be incredibly destructive,
you know,
for,
for me,
I spent five years at the fat duck.
I did a bunch of of work I'm incredibly proud of and there's many people I can
still consider strong friends,
but it was also realizing that I had created a future.
It wasn't tenable for me to stay for much longer because I was so har hardheaded
and so obstinate that it created a lot of friction between me and other senior
members of staff because I was pushing for something that I was convinced was
right.
But it basically made me very difficult to work with.
And just because you're right,
you're only going to go to get away with that so many times.
And so that was sort of the realization that a restaurant like that is built on
teamwork.
And yes,
some people can be doing really valuable work and yes,
some people can be exceptional,
are special and they do get certain amounts of dispensation.
But if that gets abused,
you're not going to be in a tenable position as soon as basically you've
delivered your value.
People aren't gonna want to work with you for much longer.
Working with people at modernists,
there was a lot of people on that team were very talented,
um,
exceptionally talented,
very difficult people to work with.
Um,
you know,
everyone involved in that project was accomplished with skillful,
um,
and had a pretty big ego to match and was pushing to do something exceptional.
We all got the work done at the end of it.
Nobody really wanted to do that again together.
Um,
I was actually lucky enough that like grant and Ryan and I still wanted to work
together after that.
But if you look at most of the team,
we sort of a scattered to the wind.
It was like,
okay,
the book's done.
We don't want to work as a team.
Was Chef steps one of the things that's really become clear to me as I work with
50 of the most exceptional people I've ever worked with,
I'm amazed at what do and what they accomplish.
The worst thing in the world for me would not be,
uh,
able to not being able to work with those people and see the types of things
they can do.
So I've really found a lot of my satisfaction is how do I enable other teams of
people?
How do we enable other people to do their best work?
That's on a good day.
How I feel about that.
I mean I have the same tension and struggles I think anyone does.
It's not like you suddenly flip a switch and you're perfect.
It's more,
I have seen how teams get blown up.
I've been a participant in that and that's really a longterm destructive pathway
to be on.
And at some point in my mid thirties,
it was like,
do you want to stay on this pathway or do you want to be able to do big,
ambitious things that take talented teams of people?
Because if so you've got to learn to basically check your ego so there's room
for other people to do their best work.
Yeah.
And something,
I mean I've,
I've struggled with this as well as also the shifting your focus from and of
course not always getting it right,
but from,
from being right to being effective,
uh,
and choosing the battles really carefully.
I was chatting with a,
uh,
I'm pretty well known political advisor,
not because I have any political aspirations,
but he,
he's become a friend of mine.
I think there might be an opening for you this season
too late.
Oh God.
Yeah.
Who knows.
Know that's a whole separate wine,
uh,
necessitating conversation.
But the,
um,
his advice to me at one point we were having wine and eating pizza and she did
was great.
This was in Venice,
California and Italy.
And I was telling him about the number of the multitude of places where I want
it to
start.
Initiatives have an impact.
And he just said to me,
he's like,
you know,
you should,
you should kind of think of this like a six shooter.
He's like,
you have six bullets.
And he's like,
you get to,
you get six bullets each year,
maybe every two years.
And he's like,
what are you going to use them on?
And that's how I've started to think a lot about kind of conflict resolution or
just conflict in general.
Like is this the fight if I only get to have six fights,
is this one of the sex,
am I going to spend a bullet on this?
And uh,
it's tough.
It's tough to follow your own advice when it comes to that stuff.
When you've been rewarded for so long for being a stubborn ass.
That is actually exactly the problem is when you are talented,
when you are good at what you do,
people will tolerate a lot of stuff.
As long as it serves their purposes,
as long as it's useful,
but you will get,
uh,
you will get no runway as soon as that,
that,
that's over.
And that's unfortunate because we're all going to hit rough patches.
We're all going to hit patches where you need people to basically cut you some
slack because you're not firing on all cylinders.
If you're basically insistent on being right all the time and,
and,
and controlling everything,
you're not going to get that slack.
If you could have one billboard anywhere with anything on it,
what would you put on that billboard?
I think it would probably have to erect it outside of my high school.
Okay.
Um,
I think I might have to erect at outside of my high school and uh,
and it,
I think,
I don't know exactly how I would art direct this,
but it's going to be something to the effect of it all worked out anyway.
[inaudible] was not a great time for me.
I love it.
Uh,
and uh,
just,
just uh,
this is the last question.
Any ask or request of the people listening,
anything they should ponder,
consider,
do or otherwise and then then we'll get to where they can find you and
everything you're up to.
Of course I have to,
uh,
I guess we'll call the call to actions.
So one,
if you're into cooking,
if you're curious about how cooking works,
come check out what we're doing at chef steps.
If you are interested in new tools,
things like that.
We have them also,
if you're essentially an awesome engineer,
whether a software engineer or a physical hardware engineer or you just amazing
at something and you,
it,
you can relate it to cooking it all.
We want to hear from you.
We want to work with more people who are passionate about cooking.
And have skills worth adding to the kitchen.
So that's,
that's the,
where would they find,
they can go to chef steps stuff.
You've got a chef,
steps.com.
There's a jobs link at the bottom.
If you don't see anything on there,
uh,
you know,
roll your own job description and tell us why we should basically take a serious
look at you.
We're,
we're,
we've,
we've hired applied mathematicians,
we've hired musicians,
we've hired a lot of unusual people that have found ways to add incredible value
at chef steps.
So we're pretty open minded there.
Um,
and if you just want to basically find some awesome cooking content or
inspiration for the kitchen or by some pretty damn cool tools,
uh,
that's another good reason to check it out.
Uh,
the other thing gliding,
um,
I have tried to introduce several people,
the gliding,
I haven't,
I haven't yet to take you up,
Mr Ferris.
I'm,
but I've taken Matt up.
I've taken quite a few and I've got a pretty good hit record of turning people
into glider pilots.
This sport could use more people.
It's awesome.
It's a blast.
Um,
you,
it,
it is incredibly compelling.
So check out,
uh,
the Soarian Society of America.
And if you're,
I dunno,
in the Bay area,
uh,
William Sorane and is a phenomenal place to learn.
There's a bunch of your leaves,
William Soaring.
Uh,
it's up near Sacramento,
but there's a bunch of other good clubs around here.
But I would encourage a lot of your listeners to check out.
Gliding it is a hell of a thing.
And it is a inc incredibly welcoming sport.
S what was it?
The soaring society of Soarian Society of America.
Ssa.
All right.
And there you have it.
So where can people,
if anywhere say hello on the social media and whatnot,
do you participate in such an entity?
So you can chef steps
on Twitter,
Facebook,
Youtube,
chef steps.com.
Of course.
And there's an APP and there's probably a bunch of social channels like
Instagram and others that I don't even know about yet.
Perfect.
Well cause it's always fun to hang and a,
we will have more adult beverages in Seattle and elsewhere soon.
I am sure.
But I appreciate you taking the time.
Thanks Tim.
It was fun and for everybody listening,
you can get links to everything that we talked about,
all the goodies in the show notes at four hour work,
week.com forward slash podcast as well as all the past episodes.
If you want to hear my chat,
which involves some Tequila with Matt Mullenweg for instance,
then you can find that episode there as well.
And until next time,
as always,
thank you for listening.
Hey guys,
this is Tim again.
Just a few more things before you take off.
Number one,
this is five bullet Friday.
Do you want to get a short email from me?
Would you enjoy getting a short email from me every Friday that provides a
little more soul of fun before the weekend and five bullet Friday is a very
short email where I share the coolest things I've found or that I've been
pondering over the week.
That could include favorite new albums that I've discovered.
It could include Gizmos and gadgets and all sorts of weird shit that I've
somehow dug up in the,
uh,
the world of the esoteric as I do.
It could include favorite articles that I've read and that I've shared with my
close friends for instance.
And it's very short.
It's just a little tiny bite of goodness before you head off for the weekend.
So if you want to receive that,
check it out.
Just go to four hour workweek.com that's four hour work,
week.com all spelled out and just drop in your email and you will get the very
next one.
And if you sign up,
I hope you enjoyed,
this episode is brought to you by Wealthfront and this is a very unique sponsor.
Wealthfront is a massively disruptive in a good way,
set it and forget it.
Investing service led by technologists from places like apple and world famous
investors.
It has exploded in popularity in the last two years and they now have more than
two and a half billion dollars under management.
In fact,
some of my very good friends,
investors in silicon valley have millions of their own money in Wealthfront.
So the question is why?
Why is it so popular?
Why is it unique?
Because you can get services previously reserved for the ultra wealthy.
But only pay pennies on the dollar for them.
And this is because they use smarter software instead of retail locations,
bloated sales teams,
et cetera.
And I'll come back to that in a second.
I suggest you check out wealthfront.com forward slash Tim take the risk
assessment quiz,
which only takes two to five minutes and they'll show you for free exactly the
portfolio they'd put you in.
And if you just want to take their advice,
run with it,
do it yourself.
You can do that or as I would,
you can set it and forget it.
And here's why.
The value of Wealthfront is in the automation of habits and strategies that
should be using on a regular basis but normally aren't great investing is a
marathon,
not a sprint,
and little things that you may or may not be familiar with.
Like automatic tax loss harvesting,
rebalancing your portfolio,
cross more than 10 asset classes and dividend reinvestment add up to very large
amounts of money over longer periods of time.
Wealthfront,
as I mentioned,
since it's using software instead of retail locations,
etc. Can offer all of this at low costs that were previously completely
impossible.
Right off the bat.
You never pay commissions or account fees for everything.
They charge 0.25% per year on assets above the first 15,000 which is managed for
free.
If you use my link,
wealthfront.com forward slash Tim,
that is less than $5 a month to invest a $30,000 account for instance.
Now,
normally when I have a sponsor on this show,
it's because I use them and recommend them.
In this case,
it's a little different.
I don't use wealth front yet because I'm not allowed to.
Here's the deal.
They wanted to sponsor this podcast,
but because of sec regulations,
companies that invest your money are not allowed to use client testimonials.
So I couldn't be a user and have them on the podcast,
but I've been so impressed by Wealthfront that I've invested a significant
amount of my own money,
at least for me,
uh,
in the team and the company itself.
So I am an investor and hope to soon use it as a client.
Now back to the recommendation as a Tim Ferriss show listener,
you'll get $15,000 managed for free if you decide to open an account,
but just start with seeing the portfolio that they would suggest for you.
Take two minutes,
fill out their questionnaire@wealthfront.com forward slash.
Tim.
It's fast,
it's free.
There's no downside that I can think of.
This episode is brought to you by audible,
which I've used for years.
I love audiobooks and I've two to recommend right off the bat.
Number one is perhaps my favorite audio book of all time and that is the
graveyard book by Neil Gaiman.
The only audiobook I've wanted to immediately listen to a second time.
As soon as I finished.
It's amazing.
You will thank me.
The graveyard book.
The second is vagabonding by Rolf Potts,
which had a huge impact on my life and formed the basis for a lot of what became
the four hour work week.
So all you need to do to get your free 30 day trial is go to audible.com forward
slash temp and you could choose one of those two books.
The graveyard book vagabonding or more than 180,000 audio programs.
So that could be a book.
That could be a magazine,
that could be a newspaper,
could be a class.
It's that easy.
Go to audible.com forward slash Tim,
that's audible.com forward slash Tim and grab a book.
Enjoy.